all right so it's 10 a.m we're going to
get started
um let's get started with the Pledge of
Allegiance
representative
allegiance to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands one nation under God
okay so first on the agenda we have a
packed agenda today
um we tried to line up uh some people to
give a holistic overarching issue with
housing
um and then I'm going to charge the
committee with
um giving us ideas to solicit more
people to get involved
um so with that I I reached out to my
contacts and got some people here today
that can present on some of the issues
that we're facing but this isn't going
to be the only presentations we'll hear
from I'm sure we'll hear it from more
and uh if anybody has any ideas I'm
certainly welcome to hear them
um but to get started I'm going to
welcome
um Bob Quinn and Crystal Norwood for New
Hampshire uh realtors association so
um thank you for coming
thank you for having us so I am uh Bob
Quinn I am the CEO of the New Hampshire
Association of Realtors
and I am Chris Norwood and I am the 2023
public policy chair for the New
Hampshire Association and I'm also an
owner of a real estate brokerage firm uh
focusing primarily in the commercial
real estate space uh but there is a
connection there with the housing crisis
so I think our role today is sort of uh
help you set the scene of where the
housing market has been recently
um and potentially where it's going uh
oftentimes we hear from folks
the thought that that the housing
inventory crisis is a result of
increasing interest rates or uh the
pandemic
um but hopefully we're going to walk you
through
um some statistics and show you that
this inventory crisis has been a long
time in the making
um and while the pandemic may have
accelerated uh some of the some of the
issues it's been going on now for at
least a decade
so if I can get this to work
um so I don't know if you guys can see
this but this is um uh our housing
affordability index
um and I'm going to hand out something
to you afterwards so you guys can all
have a copy of this but uh basically
what the index says is uh if you have
120 index that means that median income
across the state is a hundred and twenty
percent of what the median sale price of
a home is so 120 index is a good number
we're at 76 right now
so what that means is the median income
the one on the left
is the one that's everything so right
it's just that one just did a spotlight
oh yeah yeah
I mean
yeah it's just you know I will hand out
the specifics I think it's just
generally to get a sense of you know
um of what's going on so we're at the
index at 76 hope and that's a unique
thing for the first time in
um
so for the first time in uh whitson's
we've been
um
we've been Distributing this index the
numbers have dropped below 100. so the
majority of New Hampshire residents now
cannot afford and the median price of a
home in January was 415 000 the other
thing I just point to is you'll notice
um and you've hard drives C here but the
yellow line is single family homes the
blue line is condos but that
affordability number started dropping
around 2013 and you see a slow decline
um and that's going to be a theme you're
yeah representation thank you
um if you could go back to the last
slide really quick that big spike in the
middle
um is that 2008 I'm trying I can't
really see the numbers so 2010
um
yeah so that's sort of the the recession
um started in 2000 and
really nine eight nine uh and how it
impacted the Housing Industry in New
Hampshire for about four years five
years afterwards so the peak was 2013
so on me and sale price uh trend line
going the opposite way uh so pricing has
gone up and I would just point out
um you'll notice that we sort of left
median sale price uh at two hundred
thousand dollars at about 2013. we hit
300 000 five years later in 2018.
we then hit
400 000 in about two and a half years
and last year we topped out at 460 000
and that only took one year
so
um it is it sort of it is accelerating
this since 2019 pre-pandemic
single-family housing median sale price
has increased 46 percent
um
it went from 300 000 in 2019 to a peak
of 2022 of 440 thousand dollars at this
point if you just looked at uh CPI from
2019 to 2022 that would be just under
three it should be under just under 350
000. so housing obviously and we're up
we're ninety thousand dollars above that
so housing is accelerating much quicker
than CPI is just a quick question please
um you said that um it's accelerating
and it sounds like you expect that to
continue is that correct I'm going to
get to that in just one second oh thank
you
um so that's median sale price that's
one end of the equation and now we'll
look at total number of closed sales so
in January of this year
um there were a total of 628 closed
sales uh in the state of New Hampshire
that is the lowest monthly number that
we've seen since
um uh February of 2011. so
as
we've seen uh pricing increasing
closed sales are are decreasing
what about demand
um
so this is uh the days in the market for
an average single family home and you'll
notice here that we're at about in
January is about 37 days so that's the
time that it would go on the market
until you get an offer that you accept
so right now in January there was 37
days this past summer we saw it get as
low as 13 days so two weeks you've all
heard stories about houses that go on
the market on a Friday afternoon they
get 10 offers and one's accepted on
Monday
that I think it's fair to say
anecdotally you may not see that quite
as much as you did in 2020 but I'm
talking to a lot of Realtors saying hey
it's back there are lines to showings
and I'm getting many multiple offers on
properties again and keep in mind we're
talking about January and February that
is the low point of
real estate is cyclical so you're going
to start to see medium price go up in
the summer time January February is when
it's at the lowest mark representative
Reed
thank you
um not
explicitly to your point but I was
wondering if that's impacted the time it
takes to close as well is that also
gotten shorter or has that basically
been the same I think that's pretty much
been the same I don't think there's
something any we don't have any data on
that that might be something do you have
an uh do you happen to just from your
experience have about a ballpark
I wouldn't want to Ballpark it I mean
it's I've known some closings to occur
very quickly in a matter of just 10 days
I've also known closings that can
because it really does become what kind
of inspections do you want what's in the
contracts sometimes the the property
owner may want to sell the home and I've
heard stories saying we're going to stay
in this home for six months afterwards
you're going to rent it back to us or
something like that so the closing
sometimes can take a while
just
yeah cash closing would you say a cash
close goes quicker than
the finance close no question about it
okay yeah and then that's always the
challenge and we just saw it was just an
article this week about that in terms of
the increase on cash sales
um and that's really been a put a lot of
pressure on first-time homebuyers
um because obviously a first-time
homebuyer is usually younger they don't
have the cash the competition that
oftentimes occurs because you've got a
young couple who are looking to buy a
starter home at the same time you have a
retiree who may be looking to downsize
they've just sold their home obviously
looking at that median sale price
they have a lot of cash so they come to
the to the negotiation with that cash
if you're a seller more times than not
you're going to take the cash offer
because it goes quicker less chance of a
problem so
um that's also a huge a huge issue here
representative freedom
sort of a follow-up and so you made a
comparison between a young couple that
might not have a lot of cash in say an
older couple but that's also true
obviously if say corporate buyers things
of that nature they would have money up
front
of a single family home sure
well I wasn't going to bring this up and
I didn't have another presentation but
um
so I guess it's a defining a corporate
buyer in a single family home
um and I'm talking about single-family
homes Chris can talk about multi-family
so
the National Association of Realtors
just did a study on investment and
basically corporate buyers or properties
in every state in the country New
Hampshire was actually only Alaska was
had fewer of those sorts of buyers than
New Hampshire most of the corporate
buyers that are occurring um you see
them at Texas and Georgia lead the way
the reason is large corporations come in
they'll find opportunity right they're
looking for opportunities they're
looking for
undervalued homes there aren't that many
of them in the country right now but in
certain areas they are so they'll go in
they'll buy up 50 100 properties
in an underserved area and they'll fix
them up so maybe they're renting a
number 800 bucks they fix them up
knowing that they can rent them for 17
1800 to a different type of person
um and that creates obviously
gentrification and issues with uh
displacement
but in New Hampshire was four percent uh
total single-family homes were purchased
through
um uh an investment like a corporation
but keep in mind that includes llc's and
as I'm sure representative Broody can
tell you a lot of families purchase
homes through llc's as well for tax
reasons and other and other purposes so
um
okay representative Reed thank you Mr
chair for your patience and thank you
for taking my question again just to
kind of follow up on that I'm wondering
why and I am including llc's in that
um and this may be more pertinent to
multi-family so maybe we can answer that
later down the line but uh there have
been numerous reports of people who are
going into specifically to rent out
units that are paying actually over our
current market rate sometimes over 50
percent more than the current market
rate with the philosophy and this is a
direct quote saying that there's no
amount you can pay that wouldn't make
that profitable so I'm wondering how you
kind of square what you just said with
what we've seen
in those comments
I mean I'm going to let Chris answer
that question I I would just say I I
don't know anyone who would come into a
property and say I'll pay anything
because I can make my money back all
right so you should be happy to because
at some point you're gonna have to have
a spreadsheet that shows you that a
product can reoccur so I'll let when
Chris get maybe we could finish this up
I'll let them continue for a while then
I'll take more questions
all right so I just want to point out
that the days on the market the demand
for single-family housing is still
extremely strong all right so we have a
lot of demand and not a lot of closings
so why would that be
um and what we would say it's because of
inventory
and again you look at inventory here
yellow uh is the single family homes
Blue is condos there has been a study
decline in inventory
um total number of homes for sale over
the past decade yes it's sort of
accelerated during the pandemic but we
were already on the path for uh the
total number of homes being for sale so
right now in January for instance there
were 1200 they're about 1300 homes in
New Hampshire for sale you know you go
back just five years and you can easily
find up to five thousand homes uh for
sale so a significant drop in inventory
um
so I'm just going to encourage the
committee to write your questions down
you can ask right after to allow them to
present fully on everything thank you
another way of looking at inventory is
Supply uh months of Supply so this is if
everything that is on the market right
now uh were to where to sell how fast
would that be depleted
um so what healthy environment is
somewhere between four and six months
that means buyers and sellers are on
equal footing in terms of the
negotiation so we're at 1.1 months in
January and we have certainly seen that
drop below uh one month as well so
that's certainly another indication that
inventory is a problem
um
this gets to I think someone's question
regarding
um where we see things kind of where
things are headed so this is year over
year uh medium price change so this is
2022. so
um on the far left is January and the
far right is December and so the January
number would be comparing the change
from 2021 to 2022. so for instance in
January was about 14 median price
increase but as you can see as the year
has gone down gone by
pricing is still increasing from 20 in
2022 from 2021 but the rate is starting
to decline we're at uh in January it
doesn't go to January we're now at four
percent so I guess that's a big question
you know when we get to April where we
start to see that being zero but again I
think it's important to put everything
in context we're comparing 2023 to 2022
um when we all knew that there was a
significant inventory and housing
shortage
we also hear a lot of concerns a lot of
questions that hey
this is a national issue
um so New Hampshire is no different from
what's taking place elsewhere
Nationwide the National Association of
Realtors shows that there's 2.9 months
of inventory this was in December
um in New Hampshire we're at 1.3 months
so about 40 percent of what it is
nationally and if you look at certain
counties in the state it's lower than
that Hillsboro we're under one month of
inventory in the state in December
um
not every state tracks sort of this uh
months of inventory we're about where
Massachusetts is but if you go to
Pennsylvania New York New Jersey Texas
and other states they're at three
they're about three months significant
you know you want to be at that four to
six months they can kind of see it we're
still a long way from it
this next one would be hard to see so I
will I will I will email this to you but
um I just threw in here some data that
we have that's available on our um on
our website this is very specific
Community data so I picked randomly of
course Manchester hooks at New Market
and Concord
um but you'll see that in each of those
uh communities
from 2021 2022 and 23 2023 median sale
price is continuing to increase
um
yeah yeah now granted in a new market
you're looking at the number of closed
sales being pretty small but it's still
the point is uh the pricing is
increasing
and if you're interested uh in looking
at your own Community
um we do have this if you go to nhr.org
something I've called Fast stats you can
get all this data uh uh on on on your
local community and it shows sort of
historically median sale price going
back about a decade
and this is updated every single month
so you can come back and and check on it
um this is from the National Association
of Realtors so uh Dr Lawrence Yoon is
the national Economist for for the
Realtors and these are sort of his
predictions of what's going to happen uh
and also a bit of a look back so
the I'm not the the best PowerPoint but
the the red uh numbers on the home price
that's New Hampshire
so nationally for instance in 2019 it
saw 4.9 increase in New Hampshire it was
six percent
2020 it went up 9.1 New Hampshire went
up 11.7 16.9 nationally in 2021 17.9 the
important thing to remember here is this
is always compounding so when there's a
little bit of a split in terms of New
Hampshire versus nationally
um as even a one percent as you start
moving forward
you start separating even further and
that's what we're seeing New Hampshire
is always just above the rest of the
country in terms of median sale price
and we were again in 2022 actually it
was 10 and we were at 11.4 so moving
forward they're predicting uh a one
percent meaning increase so they're
looking at kind of a flat market in
terms of uh pricing which is again keep
in mind we topped that at about 460 in
2022.
but then they're looking at 2024 that's
starting to accelerate again obviously
this has impact the interest rates and
the larger economy is going to impact
this but this is kind of the snapshot
right now so with that I will turn it
over to Chris
thank you Bob and thank you members of
the committee
um so as I said before I'm Chris Norwood
and I focus primarily on Commercial Real
Estate which does also include
multi-family investment sales
um and what I just we're going to throw
a lot of data there's obviously a lot of
data on the PowerPoint I didn't present
to PowerPoint so I'm happy to summarize
any of this uh in an email
um I want to just say what I found
interesting in coming to Concord over
the last number of years in in lobbying
what you're hearing now is from
employers and we didn't used to hear
that it used to be just you know the
Realtors the housing Advocates and so
forth their employers there are chambers
of commerces the Bia and so forth that
see this as a huge thing and and I'll
let them lend their ear to this
committee uh to see how much employers
are looking and this is a this is a
Statewide issue
um a couple things on data for uh for
multi-family
if you were to go back to Bob's slide
where he talked about the median price
going from 200 000 and then accelerated
to 300 000 and then 400 and how quick
that acceleration is so I'm going to
speak specifically to Manchester for
multi-family uh sales and that's because
the data is the most robust there
um you know historically there's about
300 or so properties that sell through
the MLS of multi-families in Manchester
which gives you a pretty good sample
size
um and I will say that the majority of
the data that that I'm going to talk
about right now are the smaller stick
built ones I'm not talking about the
large 40 to 50 units those are different
classifications which I'll mention in a
moment
the four to say 10 units in the trough
of the Great Recession we're selling
Thirty to forty thousand dollars per
door
just before the pandemic they were
starting to sell between 70 and 90 000
adore right so you've got maybe it took
them about eight years to double in
price
then now
2022 if you look at those they're 120 to
150 000 a door so it took about three
years to almost double again right so
the velocity is increasing and I think
what Bob said is true the velocity of
increase is is a number of things it's
the incredibly low interest rate I
started this business 20 years ago so I
don't know interest rates higher than
you know six and a half percent right
when I started 20 years ago
um but that would that's been the norm
is if you look at the trend line we were
in some hyper hyper low interest rates
we were also in a period the last three
years of a number of stimulus dollars
coming in and a lot of these things just
compounded so I I want to just kind of
briefly mention that environment and if
you are looking on the rental rate side
obviously
um the best source of that data and I'm
also a board member of the New Hampshire
Housing Finance Authority full
disclosure
um and Ben and um Heather and their team
have great data but roughly in the last
five years the the cost of a two-bedroom
unit has grown by about 30
let's call it 30 plus or minus right
depending upon how you want to look at
it so the overall dollar amount that
people are paying for these units is
gone up uh but also the rental rates
have gone up as well
uh on the on the higher end cost of
construction let's talk about that for a
second because that's part of the
problem in my opinion we've gotten to a
point where the only type of
construction that is Affordable
those large-scale construction when you
drive down 93 you'll see large buildings
going up in Londonderry right these
large huge complexes and and I think
that there's a number of reasons behind
this but quite frankly it's economies of
scale and I think that that's the
largest reason but the price of new
construction for what I will call a
quality units not B quality like they're
in downtowns these a quality are 250 to
300 000 and that's an all-in cost
including land and what I find
interesting about the data when you look
at the cost of construction is the value
of the land is increasing but it's
nominally so so I I what I want the
committee to understand that the price
is not being driven up by people who
have held on to all this land and all of
a sudden now they're selling it and
that's really fueling the costs it's the
soft cost the legal fees the engineering
fees the architectural fees it's the
overall cost of construct action and
those costs are weighing heavily on
development projects and again I think
that that's why we're seeing these
larger scale projects because the
inflection point for construction is at
least 40 units to make a go at
um at a new project
um
just staying with that large and small
um you know why don't I just go here I I
don't want to leave here with a bunch of
negative pieces so I just want to
consider a couple
um areas where I see for for opportunity
and I think being in the field one of
the things that I see is we need to
create incentives for the small and
medium-sized contractors and how can we
get something that's less than 40 units
built because I respect the fact that
not every Community wants a hundred unit
complex sitting outside of their Main
Street and so you know some bills that
have either that are in this session or
previous sessions anything that can
support increased density particularly
where there's already Municipal Water
and Sewer and we don't have to concern
ourselves we're building excess septic
systems I think those are positive
things
adus which is something that this body
passed a number of years ago that has
been helpful but something to allow for
increased density broadly across the
state we see as a positive
um and I will I'll leave on this one
statistic which is
um
OSI and I believe correct OSI is no
longer
nhbe a now uh tracks this data
um but the OSI has been tracking for a
number of years the total number of
building permits
um and if you ever look at the data
um and you graph it everyone knows you
know Great Recession years and so forth
we were at a state producing seven to
nine thousand building permits just
before the Great Recession
by no means am I stating we should go
back to over building and we could talk
about whether seven to nine thousand was
over building but then after the Great
Recession we didn't break 3 000 for a
number of years
finally finally in 2000 I think 20 or
2021 we got up to five thousand and I
think as Bob was talking earlier there
is kind of a a there are ranges which we
should all strive to I think New
Hampshire is it needs to be in that four
to five thousand building permits per
year how we get there I want to
emphasize there's no silver bullets I
mentioned a couple bills that that I
think I personally think are positive
but uh overall we cannot seek a um a
silver bullet I think we all have to
acknowledge that we're going to have to
do a number of different things to
encourage development to increase that
Supply I'm happy to answer any questions
thank you um are there questions from
thank you Mr chairman
um
Mr Quinn you had mentioned that there
had been a steady decline in the
inventory of homes for sale in New
Hampshire so the question that I wanted
to ask is do you have any idea why this
is so
so I think I mean I don't think there's
just again there's probably not one
answer to that I mean obviously a lot of
folks want to come to New Hampshire
um it's we've seen although it's
happening now in Maine and Vermont as
well there's been more of an influx into
the state than you've seen in other
parts certainly of New England where
there maybe has been an outflow of of
population
but clearly I think it gets to Chris's
point which post recession the number of
permits that were being issued were
extraordinarily low so we weren't
building enough homes units apartments
in order to satisfy the demand and I
think that's you know the simple part of
it you know and
we kind of believe if the legislature
empowers
um
the individual the private property
owner to utilize their property in a
manner that they feel is of best use
then a lot of this inventory issue
will subside over time it's oftentimes
When government local governments
especially kind of get involved it can
really increase dramatically the price
of of construction and in some ways
limit the ability of that property owner
to provide the necessary units the state
needs representative
thank you
um in in your discussions about the
selling price
um
you're you are essentially
I think kind of grouping everything
together do you have any data as far as
like dollar per square foot if that is
going up or a dollar per acre
um as far as
um
maybe I guess that would that would help
as far as
what types of buildings maybe
you know is this
a building that was previously one
hundred thousand dollars and is Tiny and
now it's four hundred thousand dollars
that's being sold or are we just
building giant buildings and not
building small buildings that would
would possibly bring this number down is
kind of what I'm
um if you but you know if you built a
smaller building that was a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars that might bring
the average down whereas if we're
building all four hundred thousand
dollar houses then obviously the the
median is going to be above four hundred
thousand right and so that information
and if I could one not statistics but
anecdotally we are building more and
more studios in more and more really
efficiencies you know 500-ish square
feet and
um we're no longer building as many two
three and four bedroom units and we can
talk about motivations behind that but I
mean I know my first plate crash pad out
of college was a three bedroom unit we
split it three ways
um but now you have an efficiency which
cost you know that same price point
um but the newer construction or the new
trend in multi-family tends to be uh
smaller smaller units
and then just to go to your your point I
think the key I think we would want to
underscore is the need for more density
um so whether or not that's multi-family
or it's single-family homes a
subdivision uh developers can build more
densely it's good for the developer and
it's also good for the the potential
renter or buyer because they can do
things at a more affordable price
density great represent representative
McConkey after
thank you Mr chairman um I appreciate
the presentation today I think it's very
informative
um on a more Cosmic level Beyond
excuse me
um just identifying the problem but
justifying fixing the problem
in the legislature especially in last
year with a couple of the four Flex
bills one of the arguments that I heard
made from the floor of the house was
well a lot of us in the legislature have
invested our time and money over the
years and now our home value has gone up
and we are concerned that passing this
four Plex bill will decrease the value
of those homes and it seems that one of
the major roadblocks to addressing this
very important problem is the fact that
some folks will see
a threat in a decrease of the value of
their homes so I'm kind of curious as to
what the elevator pitch is from the New
Hampshire Realtors association as far as
the justification for not just
identifying the problem but why it's
foreign
specifically to that bill representative
but I think in general
um our communities Thrive when there are
people moving in and I think that we in
New Hampshire we've been fortunate even
though we've had a declining birth rate
declining School population for about
two decades now
um we've we've been the beneficiary of
net in migration and I think the
challenge that I see generally for all
housing bills is if we stop seeing that
net in migration if we stop giving
opportunities for people to come in and
uh grow and have kids
um those are the people that make the
community Thrive those are the people
working those are the people spending
money at the local coffee shops
um and so I I think that perhaps again
not specifically to that bill but I see
any sort of increase in the number of
homes being built in a community or or a
denser apartment building being built in
an urban environment I see that as money
that is going to help the beauty Salon
the coffee shop
the et cetera et cetera so I see it as
any other questions represent McConkey
thank you
foreign
appreciate that
um for Mr Norwood they you spoke of um
in the Manchester area that uh
multi-family four to five units I think
you were speaking four to ten units you
used a number of the selling price or
buying price right now to be somewhere
between 120 150 a door I understand that
do you have any data that tells you as
you move north of Concord where that
number is at a 10 20 percent less do you
have any data like that please I can
grab that data and I think the Bob said
it earlier is
um the data becomes thinner so it's I I
just want to be cautious that we don't
try and make any conclusions off of one
property that could skew it but we
certainly can look up that data and Mr
chairman uh if we could just ask that
the
that the presentation be sent to you and
then distributed us if you would please
that'd be great thank you representative
Lorenzo thank you Mr chair and my
question is for Chris
um in order to sort of like work around
the
um
the desire of
towns
to keep the density um low would it be
possible to do a sort of like I say a
100 unit scattered site project to beat
the density conundrum and does that work
with economies of scale in mind so I'm
thinking about
um
faced like phase construction for
instance um a developer buys five
Parcels in a town
um and then you know of course they
scattered in different areas so
would it be feasible to develop 100
units phasing in
um
the project and representative thank you
for the question and it is a a personal
passion of mine to figure out that
riddle
um there are challenges broadly speaking
in terms of engineering uh needing
multiple driveways driveways that you
can get a fire truck through right so
it's not it's not just
um aesthetic issues there are life
safety concerns for scattered sites as
well
um but I I understand and I do think
that that's
um that should be part of the solution
and whether or not it's a large
developer putting in three sites
scattered throughout a neighborhood or
whether that is a smaller person who
somehow we can make the economies work
to put up a 12 unit that may not be as
offensive perhaps to other questions
um in the community may be more positive
representative Gibbs thank you
um as a follow-up on representative De
Lorenzo's question
um are you familiar with the use of
scattered site development
um in federally funded housing
um I should tell you I'm a 29-year
employee of the U.S Department of
Housing and Urban Development and
um was involved with many uh
developments of various types of federal
funding and Scattered site
scattered site development became more
and more common over the years that I
worked there and has been done
successfully in many places throughout
New England
representative let's connect after this
because that's that's awesome to hear
and I'm not as familiar with that no I'd
like to learn more
representative Reed
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um speaking of more scattered
decentralized methods of getting to
increase Supply I heard you say probably
my current three favorite letters which
is Adu
and for full disclosure I'm the prime
sponsor of the Adu bill
um
oh I'm sorry yes accessory dwelling
units currently I think the year before
I was elected a bill passed to allow
every homeowner occupied owner occupied
homeowner to build one accessory
dwelling unit
um towns were allowed to have certain
restrictions on them but they would have
it by right I'm in Greece I have in my
bill proposed to increase that to two
with certain other restrictions in place
so sorry for the background uh so my
question is um because it seems that you
kind of support this but the committee
recently it yelled it uh on what I
believe to be misunderstandings of the
situation one of the things they said
was they were afraid well I heard after
the fact that they were worried about
um property values and is it your
experience places that have built adus
somehow decreased the neighborhood
property values at all
to kind of reference representative
adjectives question
so
um we are not appraisers so it may be a
good idea to bring in an appraiser at
some point however I've talked to a
praise about this issue because it comes
up quite a bit
there was a tiny home built a couple of
years ago same organ was made
and I talk to appraisers and they could
they were like listen you can't make
that judgment
um on a global scale you'd have to know
exactly what's the neighborhood is what
it looks like but they said generally
that's not going to be a factor as
they're appraising a property so yeah we
wouldn't certainly
um find that to be
and just to follow up very briefly if
the chair would allow it
um so obviously usually it increases the
actual that actual property value of
that property that has more because and
it helps home buyers buy homes because
if you have rental income inherent in
your property you can afford your
mortgage more easily but in terms you're
saying in terms of the neighborhood
values it doesn't there's no reason to
expect especially in the trickle way
that adus would be built not a wave but
yeah okay thank you and I would I would
just point out also on the Adu issue
um an example just talking to somebody
so they're developing an Adu in
Manchester their mother is going to
leave her home in Manchester and move
into the Adu now her mother's home is
going to be available for someone to
move in
all right the value of his home is going
to increase he's going to end up paying
more in property taxes for that so the
city is going to benefit nobody is
utilizing any Services more than they
were before so it's a great opportunity
um uh for that type of activity what we
always say is sort of a we we want to
see everything everything above the line
anything you can think of helps because
the most important thing is your people
are moving around you can't it's very
challenging to build a single family
home it doesn't really matter what size
it is just because of all of the the the
soft costing that's going to be less
than five hundred thousand dollars but
don't look at that as being necessarily
a bad thing because a first-time
homebuyer can't afford it someone who
was in a 300 000 house currently is
going to move into that 500 000 home and
that frees up their 300 000 home right
and maybe that person is buying a 300
000 home was in an apartment now their
apartment's going to be available
so the more
housing we have period it's going to
start alleviating some of these issues
so it's sort of a everything everything
thank you
um you
I guess it's possible you don't know but
um
uh the adus
have been around for for a number of
years have you seen
um
issues
with maybe people that want to to put in
adus and are not able to is is there is
there demand I guess for uh for houses
with adus already built have you seen
any kind of like desire to see that uh
and and is there any struggles that you
know about
um or maybe
um people that we should talk to as far
as as struggles that um about
implementing those
I think as far as adu's and we certainly
uh I can think of a couple stories but
one in particular where it's not a slam
dunk to get an Adu so just because we
have now a bill previously passed that
said you know you can build an Adu on
your residence doesn't mean that you can
just go in tomorrow and just start
building
um and and oftentimes there's a lot of
regulatory environment that exists
within the town or the city that can be
daunting and can take months so whether
or not this body should start creating a
a fast lane so to speak for that that
that's maybe another policy type
question but I will say that it's uh
it's not just um just because we passed
that bill a number of years ago doesn't
mean that you can go out tomorrow and
put up an edu towns still do have
authority
um to make sure that the adus you know
have size restrictions and so forth
representative
yeah thank you Mr chair thanks for
taking my questions
um the first one I have two actually if
it's okay first one goes to cost and I
saw some of the graphs from this
distance showing the spike in in
building cost of forfeit well I mean the
the the sale cost right now
let me what was the fact the effect or
do you have any statistics to show
percentage-wise how much the cost of
building materials affected
the total costs only because I'm in the
business and I know everything
quadrupled basically
um and so that head will have a bearing
I don't know if you know how much of a
bearing
and then a similar follow-up to it is
now that things have settled down to
about maybe 10 percent more than they
were pre-covered do you see the price
maybe trending down again
um I'm actually going to look and maybe
yeah so I think you're going to get a
good Insight on the construction cost
from folks that are building they can
probably answer the question better than
I okay and if I can't this one is
probably for them uh you mentioned the
healthy amount of building permits uh
do you have any data that shows it
regionally
um town by Town even possibly only
because I read an article somewhere
before I knew I was going to be on this
committee that a lot of the towns in
Southern New Hampshire have actually
increased their inventory from two to
three hundred percent but it was
actually the municipalities the larger
towns that were only growing at about 40
percent
so it'd be neat to see if we could just
look at it regionally
so uh this used to be the office of
strategic initiatives who put out this
now it's New Hampshire Bea who I see
behind me
um so they can give you uh sort of an
update on that I I think that it does
get to a point though and another issue
as you're thinking about a public policy
uh position moving forward is we see
certain communities which are working
diligently to expand permitting and
increase the inventory of housing we see
other communities who are not
um as open to that who might be
neighboring so we talk about local
control it we all want local control we
all respect the need for it but at times
there also has to be recognition that
sometimes one Town's local control
starts to negatively impact a
neighboring Town's local control and
we've seen that in a number of
communities across the state
um so it's something also to consider as
you're moving forward with Solutions
thank you and Owen if you could send
that over to us or no I'm sorry no if
you can send that over to us that'd be
great thank you
representative Rudy okay thank you Mr
chairman um finally
the cost of housing has been so much is
um we see a lot of out-of-state buyers
coming in do you have any numbers of
people from out of state coming in and
where they're coming in from so
representative baruti actually wrote
Massachusetts New Hampshire on the top
of my page because I did want to say
that that was mentioned earlier
um we do not but I know that Ben and
Heather from New Hampshire Housing
Finance did do a study and they looked
at 21 over 20 2020 I don't know if they
have 22 over 21 yet but um listen I
drive by an open house all I see are
Massachusetts plates at least that's
what I think I see right but but the
reality is is when we look at the data
um there is there has been an increase
it was as I recall a two to three
percent increase of overall out-of-state
buyers not just Massachusetts let's not
just pick on them
um and so it is an increase but it's not
as dramatic Statewide locally Rockingham
County Hillsborough County I think that
there we need to do look at the data a
little bit more narrowly but it's
um Massachusetts isn't the only one to
blame for our problem
but uh yeah I do believe New Hampshire
housing does have that data okay thank
you awesome um representative Reed thank
you
um once again so I want to kind of I
don't think you'll have this information
I'm gonna I'm gonna ask you anyway
um because when we talk about oh out of
state buyers there's this like kind of
negative like oh no but we also at the
same time talk all the time about trying
to attract more young people to the
state that means out of state buyers so
do you have data on what percentage of
those people might be younger
uh thank you representative for the
question uh the data that I believe was
collected and talked to Ben and Heather
but I believe it was based upon the
registry of deeds information and where
they're in outbound deed and their
inbound deed was those types of things
so that wouldn't capture their age or
any other demographic profile
thank you great does anyone else can we
have questions
great thank you very much thank you very
much
all right so I'm going to pass this off
representative Rudy to introduce our
next Witnesses
if you'd like to anybody need a break
okay all right let's go right into it
foreign
all right
um it's my great pleasure to introduce
you to our a company out of I don't know
where they're from now Manchester hooks
um
the Elm Grove company is a very very
um well-known well-respected
um real estate company developer and
they have a lot of affordable housing
um
they will kind of touch on everything
from Soup To Nuts on
how they acquire property
how they finance it how they build it
how they manage it
and this is a One-Stop
shop when it comes to uh affordable
housing because they're going to be
probably one of the biggest affordable
housing landlords in the state
they're very well respected as I said
um
I know that in September it'll be nine
years when I was diagnosed with cancer
and I wound up going to Elm Grove and
they took me in my office in and
babysately people while I was going
through treatments and I'll never forget
that
um a great group to work with
and like I said it's a big asset to the
community
to moving out of Manchester into
Hooksett so hooksett's going to have a a
great company to work with they're going
to be a Jewel for Hooksett believe me so
without further Ado I don't know who's
going to be doing the speaking but
Newton you want to introduce your people
yeah perfect off can you guys hear me
okay
thank you representative Broody I'm
Newton Kershaw I'm a principal at Elm
Grove companies
um I'll try to give a just a high level
overview about what our company is and
our experiences of a context do you want
to introduce your other people too and
do you need access to the the TV
PowerPoint or anything
um so and then I'm going to be
introducing my partner Matt and Chris in
from a technology perspective Matt can
answer that question we have someone
patched in from Florida which I think is
just going to be on this computer so I
think we should be self-sufficient there
okay
so
um at Elm Grove we have our headquarters
in Manchester you alluded to us moving
to Hooksett we are trying to move our
headquarters there that's true
um we are a vertically integrated Real
Estate Investment Company
so what that means is we have about 85
employees
we do our own construction our own
property management our own property
maintenance we have a brokerage meaning
a real estate brokerage arm and
currently we own and operate about 1 500
Apartments
those are our own apartments and we also
do third party Property Management
the majority are our own Apartments
of those apartments that we do we do
both market rate Apartments
in affordable apartments and so by
definition market rate means there's no
restrictions to the rents on that are
able to be had there just with the
market commands and affordable means
that there is a ceiling on you know the
amount of rent that we can charge
um historically we have done
um what are called flips we've bought
renovated and resold over 400
single-family homes and over 65
communities
we've built ground up single-family
homes so that is not something that we
do now historically we've done a lot of
renovation of pre-existing distressed
properties but in addition to that now
we're also building out of the ground
including low-income housing tax credit
projects one of which is in Salem New
Hampshire we're building 74 Apartments
out of the ground now
um we are converting 96 Apartments in
Rochester New Hampshire from market rate
to Affordable those were built in 1987
we're converting those and working to
develop another two or three hundred
units out of the ground via permitting
in Rochester New Hampshire so that's
kind of a broad brush of the types of
things that we get into and
representative barood who said for me to
bring in some materials I'll pass around
a little brochure that we had put
together when we renovated some property
here in Concord back in 2017.
um so I'll just pass that around but I'm
going to pass it off to my partner Matt
minning who is our director of
operations and head of operations and
also Chris schleyer who is our partner
and head of property management thank
you
thank you for the opportunity to come up
and thanks for inviting us
representative Broody
um
we hope that today we don't have a slide
deck and a big presentation I want to
talk at you for an hour and a half uh
would be just more of a discussion and
we've also invited which I'll reveal in
a second uh Stephen Lewis uh he is
trying to get into retirement and is
almost there so he's joining us from
Florida
um Stephen is a very seasoned developer
in the state we've been working with him
closely over the past couple of years on
our
affordable development management and so
we felt that inviting him
to join us today would really augment
the uh
the presentation and discussion Steve
has had a lot of
a lot of experience in multiple
communities with planning boards zoning
boards working with New Hampshire
housing
dating back to the 1980s and he's
developed I'll let Steve
discussed that but he's done dozens of
projects maybe maybe hundreds we'll see
but he's very very experienced and uh
the way I think we would organize maybe
the discussion
and you tell us if this works but start
at the at the first part of the
development phase Land Development
permitting entitlement
then move into the financing
underwriting construction and finally
the lease up management and ongoing
compliance especially as it relates to
the low income housing tax credit
programs I think that sounds great and I
think
um specifically maybe outline some of
the roadblocks that you'd run into at
each step of the process too would be
great for the committee perfect so I
think with that I'll probably Steve turn
you around here and make sure everyone
can hear you can you hear us Steve
yeah let me turn you so you can face the
committee
uh can you everyone hear Steve all right
all right how about now
all right so Steve if you want to
introduce yourself a little bit and uh
you can start off with the Land
Development Area
well I think to begin with I'm not a
stranger to being in in front of the
legislature and testifying on housing
issues uh more closely with Elliot Berry
at New Hampshire legal
ization which may seem like a strange
marriage but housing is not a partisan
issue housing is not a left or a right
issue
um I think uh one of the things that's
important for you to know is that I'm an
endangered specie because I'm actually
in New Hampshire native who still lives
in the community he was born in
and I'm past president of New Hampshire
hotels Association so
um that's kind of a background and don't
hold it against me I did work for the
Department of Commerce for three years
please don't hold that one against me
um but basically I think it's important
to know that I have been involved in the
affordable housing industry uh since
I started in the building business in
1972.
uh yes I am older than dirt
um but interestingly I got involved in
the affordable side of it when I was
accosted by a former school teacher
complaining why she was forced to move
out of the community she had lived in
all her life now that she was retired
and she blamed me the Builder for not
producing affordable housing and when I
told her I'm not allowed to build
affordable housing she thought I was
coming up with an excuse
and I think this story is interesting uh
back at that point there was a New
Hampshire Housing Commission which uh I
hardly suggest that you might think of
re-upping again because the New
Hampshire housing commission's entire
sole Focus was housing advocacy and
making sure that local communities just
follow New Hampshire's
constitutional law
and I invited them to come to a planning
board meeting
and I said I would propose an affordable
senior housing project and I wanted them
to see what would happen so the New
Hampshire housing uh the director of New
Hampshire housing
Commission
and Dolores desotel from HUD and the
school teacher went to a planning board
meeting and they said why are you
proposing this you know Ms Lewis we
don't allow it I said well I would just
like to know what your feelings are
about providing affordable senior
housing in this community and they went
around the room and they said we don't
want those kind of people in our
community
now if I had said I don't want to build
units for those kind of people I would
violate the federal fair housing unit
so
um if you want to know the roadblocks
that was 26 years ago and
it's still out there and unfortunately
it's more of a lack of information
I think there are people that have
misconceptions about the effects of
affordable housing in a community
and um
I think uh this is not an isolated
example
uh but
um
that meeting resulted in a four-year
class action lawsuit
and we actually proved that the ton of
Atkinson literally discriminated against
low and middle income people by their
zoning practices
and
um
I know that sounds harsh but it was the
best thing that happened if you ask
people in Atkinson now
this guy didn't fall Chicken Little was
wrong Atkinson has balanced housing and
we have one of the lowest tax rates in
Rockingham County
so that's just the background
um
there are there are I'm here to answer
questions about what you can do in a
positive way but after that lawsuit
um
I had built a very successful project
um senior project in Atkinson I built a
very successful projects in uh Salem New
Hampshire I am now being approached by
communities
Mr Lewis would you
do a project here because we know
um it will be done and we won't get sued
so it's sort of respect and fear produce
a similar result
um
there are some things that I if you
would like I can send you there's an
independent study done by Bruce Mayberry
um commissioned by New Hampshire
Authority
um it is a two-year study on the effects
of affordable housing on a community he
studied all the low-income housing tax
credit projects that have been built in
the last 10 to 12 years that is a very
important study because it's an
independent third-party study and it
smashes the myths many communities have
about the negative effects of horrible
housing because that's the biggest
problem in the state
a prejudice against
Workforce housing
those kind of people has been said to me
more than once unfortunately
so
I won't go into any more
stories but I think attitude impacts a
housing crisis so when somebody says why
does New Hampshire have a housing
shortage it is completely man-made
I'm sure that this committee has heard
that message before we're probably just
trying to reinforce that um it the the
difference between different
municipalities and how they approach
housing whether it's affordable or
market rate single family is very very
different you have towns that are very
supportive that are very open to
facilitating the process and we have
towns that are very against it to the
point of
discrimination right um right the is the
committee aware of the I think it was a
year or two ago that Josiah Bartlett did
a center to study on the impact of
different zoning
regulations throughout the state if not
we could follow up with that as well and
we have another
um presentation later today specifically
on zoning there's some new research out
on New Hampshire zoning okay good yeah
that's I in terms of obstacles
it's it's one of the biggest and you and
from a developer's standpoint
you are either faced with the decision
that Steve had of starting a lawsuit to
try to move a project forward or just
not doing business in that town and then
that town doesn't have housing built so
you've got a fraction then of the state
that's really kind of
open for business to build to build new
housing and the way they do it is you'll
learn a lot more I'm sure uh setbacks uh
minimum uh lot sizes density
restrictions
many many barriers to building the type
of
property that can be built in an
affordable fashion right density is huge
if you need to have a 50 Acre Site to
build 50 units
the land costs make it a non-starter
immediately
um if you even get the approval in the
first place right there's many other
ways that planning boards can slow down
the process that's another big big
problem is the time it takes Steve I
don't know if you know if you have any
stories of
the longest and the shortest time it's
taken to get permits and entitlement but
it's minimum a year and a half in my
experience
it's a year and a half but one of the
things that Toms have done and sort of
there's no we're providing for
holding the number of units for building
I'm not talking about increasing density
but when a community sends you if you
want to do affordable housing they have
to be uh and duplex of quadruplex there
is no a that you can create an
affordable housing unit without shared
economies of you know
units being stacked together so that's
one of the classic
things that can be communities restrict
the number of units per building
and there are so many
unique and positive ways to build
affordable housing without destroying if
I hear one more time the rural character
of a community well
traditional New England communities had
all forms of affordability in housing
it's only in the recent in the 20 years
with the influx of new people
well I was supposedly coming to New
Hampshire for the New Hampshire Spirit
have changed it through these
exclusionary practices
but
um
there are there I think it would be good
to invite uh communities who have worked
on and developed successful affordable
housing overlay zoning
that can prove that it's not
wall-to-ball Apartments I know that um
in Londonderry the former Town manager
Kevin Smith
came up with a unique way of doing it I
know Ross Waldorf Salem's Town planner
sat down and we worked together they
gotta they got a grant from New
Hampshire Housing Finance Authority to
develop an overlay for workless housing
I think those experiences might be
helpful and I'm sure they would be
willing to come and share how they did
it
represent broody thank you Mr chairman
um we can't help with local zoning and
planning the boards too
we um
yeah
we were we were formed to
study this problem and see if there's
something we can do on a state level to
help you to help the process along
you know like we don't have home rule
here but I think we can pass something
down the line that might be able to help
and we're looking to you for
the problem you think we can fix
thank you
is there any that was not okay
representative Gibbs thank you Mr
chairman
um uh Steve um I was very impressed by
your story about
um uh being able to uh resolve the
problems in terms of developing
affordable senior housing
um as we all know it is much more
difficult to develop
um affordable family housing than even
than it is to develop affordable senior
housing and I wonder if you have any
stories that are relevant to uh efforts
to develop affordable affordable family
housing
yes well first
uh thank you for bringing that up
um I started with affordable senior
housing because I was accosted by a
school teacher who was mad at me for not
doing affordable senior housing but I
have I grew up for
me to know that I lived in a house that
had no sense of no Central Plumbing and
so when I talked to these pompous plenty
board members sometimes I guess I'm one
of those kind of people but I have made
it as I got older my give back is I do
not do a project unless 50 of the units
are Workforce and I found communities
willing to negotiate that and and say
okay we're going to allow you
at 20 density increase
and you do it in a planned unit
development
that you can't see from the road at
least 50 percent of the affordable units
must be family
um and it's worked it's worked in in
Salem it's it's working in other
communities uh that I
worked in uh but it's a negotiation your
committee on what the state can do
if the state would just enforce its
existing we don't need any new laws
towns are violating
the laws towns are violating New
Hampshire's Constitution
uh um I know you don't want a whole
bunch of printed stuff but I would I
would like to send you the study but I'd
also like to send you the Master's
report
on our discrimination lawsuit that's
quotes New Hampshire's Constitution
section by section pointing out that the
free flow of people between communities
is a right under New Hampshire's
Constitution and communities Matt had
mentioned how one Community will block
it and what happens it's unfair to the
other communities that are allowing it
because they are dumped on Dairy is a
perfect example of a community which
allowed multi-family in all the uh
bedroom communities around it said go
live in Dairy Atkinson used to say go
live in Haverhill Mass so that
social engineering and Community is
against the law and unconstitution
do you get help by
creating a an authority that doesn't
depend on
um money that there's someone out there
that's independent objective that looks
into communities for violating Law
Without something having to sue I'm glad
there's a housing board of appeals but
there should be a process where you
shouldn't have to get Equity by suing
someone
uh so
you really should look at
reconstituting the New Hampshire Housing
Commission it wasn't an expensive I
think it had at the most two or three
employees
and it was independent
uh that's something you could look into
I would I would really Echo Steve's
follow-up Mr chairman
it would help
you know New Hampshire Housing Finance
Authority which was given that task 20
years ago they're busy trying to loan
out
money to create affordable housing they
don't have the time to do the advocacy
and they're also a little concerned they
don't want to irritate
uh someone in the legislature and then
they might get less money for next
year's affordable housing so it really
is a unique
job in most States
have a separate housing commission for
that reason uh to make it independent
um that would it would be there are
plenty more members that just want to
know what to do that's right and it
would be nice if there was a state
agency that was there
with their sole responsibility uh I I
would like to send you the Master's
report because he's done all your
homework he analyzed what was wrong with
uh local communities exclusionary Zone
and he pointed out where they violate
New Hampshire law and that lawsuit
changed zoning in our area
but it was in the southern part of the
state where exclusionary zoning started
thank you Stephen representative Gibbs
thank you uh I would be very grateful to
receive a copy of that study uh on the
effect of inclusionary zoning
I I will send both of those uh I'm sure
Matt just get me who would like them and
I'll email them I have them
electronically if you can send that to
the entire committee that would be great
Mr Lewis thank you um representative
we'll help facilitate that all right
thank you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question I'm one of those pompous
planning board people
uh the study that you are going to
provide I'll ask the same question I did
before is there any data out there from
anybody that can look at what you call
balanced housing and Which towns have
the study that I'm referring to shows
the uh effects of affordable housing on
communities they don't we did we didn't
point fingers we didn't name who abused
it we just demonstrated so people can
see that the affordable housing doesn't
lower property values doesn't create
traffic problems you would you would be
I was even surprised at the density in
these projects how many school children
they produce that's important
information that is many times
misconstrued or intentionally
misconstrued I've had that happen uh
where they're saying this Workforce
housing project is going to cause
40 children in the school system and the
best source of statistical information
are the existing projects in New
Hampshire my
Workforce housing projects
um
per capita per unit how many
children do you think are in a typical
Workforce housing building
per unit
um we're not going to have the committee
answer that question I'd I'd just like
you to let us know if you could
per unit is 1.25
and the number of children School
children and an average building of 30
units is about three
not what you would say
and that's because the average occupancy
in a workplace housing project is a
single parent with hi
or believe it or not a divorced person
with no children who is working in the
local restaurant or working at Walmart
uh and that's another misconception
workplus housing people have to work
they have to have a
um
background check they have to have a
credit check so there's a misconception
socialized
subsidized people sitting on the front
step all day long it's just not true if
I may add to that uh
the I think the misconception comes from
another form of affordable housing which
is project-based Section 8 housing which
is subsidized rent and and in those
cases I think the stigma may be more
accurate and you don't see a lot of
those projects being started these days
the low income housing tax credit
program
restricts the rent but the the resident
still is expected to have income and to
pay that rent rather than having a
subsidized okay representative Walsh
yeah thank you Mr chair for the
follow-up I guess I'm still trying to
get the question answered are there any
studies out there by anybody whether
it's the planning commissions
that actually can show you what each
town has in housing type inventories
that's the answer that's the question
it's either a yes or no I would have to
check and Steve you may know but I
believe that the the Bartlett study may
have Dr right right so when we say that
I believe that's in there
Ben Frost is presenting today at um 1
30.
there's a good person to ask
because he's not only a lawyer don't
hold that against him he's also a degree
planner and he used to
uh director of the New Hampshire
um
office
estate plan so he has been in this and
he's a planning board member
he would he would be an enormously
positive source for statistical
information
representative Gibbs and then
representative thank you uh just in
reference to
um Section 8 housing
um
okay
um I I can't phrase this as a question
it's just going to have to be a
statement
um I'm uh a retired HUD employee of 29
years I'm very familiar with federally
funded housing including section 8.
um uh indeed there is very little
um Section 8 Project based housing uh
being done anymore uh
and uh certainly
um when you refer to uh something being
subsidized obviously Section 8 housing
is subsidized that's what section 8
means it's a sub it's a federal subsidy
uh and indeed there is a lot of stigma
out there about
um
federally subsidized housing uh as to
whether the stigma is accurate that the
residents of that housing are sitting on
their front steps all day living on
other people's money uh that is
something that
um uh I would say is not accurate and I
just wanted to put that out there again
as someone who's very familiar with
these issues thank you I I I would tend
to agree with you
um that seems to be what people picture
right when you have these kind of
conversations and you're trying to
trying to fight against that
that image
um
whether it's Section 8 or low income
housing tax credit
people picture what you just stated
right people sitting on on the front
steps not working right and it's and
it's very instructive
to take uh
people who aren't familiar around to a
group of properties
and show them you know hey here's we'll
do a tour for a day we'll look at five
or six properties at the end you ask
them all right so which of those do you
think were Workforce or affordable
housing which were market rate
and we kind of do a little trick because
they're all Workforce and they're all
beautiful you know they look just like
market rate housing
um they they're well landscaped the
facades are nice the the the cars in the
parking lot are what you'd expect
they're very
very normal very it meets the
expectation of what housing would be as
any kind of apartment community
um people's eyes are are open pretty
wide with that so I don't know if that's
within the purview of the committee but
you know sort of a awareness campaign or
an education campaign
um maybe through a Housing Commission
Steve suggests would be
would be valuable make it uh mandatory
training for Town officials I don't know
um we tried that though or that has been
tried before so okay
mandatory really really hurts feelings
so
um representative
Section 8 project in Hampton New
Hampshire
I could be wrong but I believe there is
no such thing as new Section 8 projects
in the entire nation that project was
done away with there is existing Section
8 vouchers but there are no new Section
8 construction projects so I agree that
it's an education project and this by
having a
a commission that sold Duty uh to
correct some of this misinformation uh
but it is a Prejudice that people have
that's unfounded and can be easily
dispelled by
education
um again
uh and I didn't I didn't mean to offend
anybody but if you knew the sarcastic
comments that have been said about me by
planning board members who don't know me
and don't know my background
um
there there are some people that are on
boards not for the reason of doing
planning but for the reason of social
engineering their community and now I
sound like some left-wing
trust me I grew up on a farm
and
um my father was put out of business by
the people that moved into our town and
changed how property was assessed and
then they couldn't understand why all
the Farms disappeared because they
assessed the farmers who had lots of
Frontage on existing streets as if they
were individual laws
the tax bills came in my father couldn't
afford to keep the farm because his tax
bill went from like two thousand dollars
to thirty thousand dollars and it was
all done by
that
social engineering of changing the
zoning and and and so which forced my
father to sell this property to a
developer and they subdivided the farm
so they created the problem they were
trying to avoid
and that's a true story my father's sold
milk to put milk company and was forced
out of business by zoning
representative thank you
um
so I I'm actually interested in the
communities being outed
um as far as
um
like there was some talk about how
Londonderry was maybe doing some stuff
right but I'm also interested in
communities that are that are um closed
for business as far as housing
um
whether or not
you feel comfortable doing that
you know in this meeting that's fine you
can do it in in via email or whatever as
far as like look uh towns that may
um have zoning that is not uh receptive
to housing so and and even rules within
the zoning that may be onerous or
inappropriate
um I know that I try and find those
things in my own local community and I
do as much as I can to find other
communities
um the information in other communities
but it's definitely with you know 200
and 40 plus communities is hard
um to be be up to date on all the
different communities so examples in of
some uh
communities would be definitely helpful
for me to you know be able to imp to be
able to pinpoint like this is an issue
and then see if it's in other
communities and especially
um when I'm trying to talk with other
legislators that's
view that local control is you know
Paramount
um I have to be able to have examples of
abuses of that to be able to dispel that
they're just you know that no guidance
or guard rails need to be placed in in
to protect the property rights of the
individuals so in Mr Lewis without
without you know naming specific towns
maybe give us like some rules that
you've seen that or or or ordinances
that may have conflicted I could I could
take that for a second too I believe the
the Bartlett study actually gives a bit
of a scorecard
for how restrictive or non-restrictive
towns are and they they actually list
out the top offenders and the top uh I
guess
you know helpful towns um so I think
that study will be very helpful from a
from a full perspective
um I'm sure Steve or or we could share a
few anecdotes as well if you'd like
um well no he wants specifics uh I will
send you specifics they exist right now
but one of the biggest subtle ways to
prevent affordable housing because the
most affordable form of housing is
rental housing and uh I could give you a
list of communities that say you can't
build in a multi-family structure over
four units
that's very clear there's the the
density
uh requirements even if there is
multi-family zoning in a town if the
density requirements are very
extreme then that requires a developer
to get a variance anytime you have to
get a variance and you'll have it by
right
There's an opportunity for the local
officials to knock that proposal down
and make it either drag out forever or
just have an outright no so uh
setbacks or another thing it's sort of
like the density argument if you have
really large setbacks you take a four
acre lot and now you only have
2.8 Acres you can actually build on
right
um excess the frontage requirements yeah
from an environmental standpoint
standpoint horrible way to do your
zoning because then you turn over these
lots of mcmansions with three or four
hundred feet of Frontage that the town's
taxpayers eventually have to get paid
repair but
um there are other other even more
Draconian things that towns have done
uh
I will give you the time I mean Pembroke
is a really good example
um
they say that they've met the
horrible housing quota except for when
you ask them show me the study they
don't have it
um Wyndham is a classic example uh and
it's interesting the wealthiest
Community the more restrictive and less
willing to provide for other economic
levels of housing I doubt it will be a
surprise Hanover is up there with one of
the most restrictive zoning rules
and I think it's a that's the 10 acre
lot size to even build a single family
if I'm not wrong right it's either five
or ten it's
people
and they're and what they hide behind is
to get a master plan you
know a questionnaire that you could
write the question a certain way
that you'll get the response you want
and if they're saying we're trying to
preserve the real character
grid pattern make mansions do not
preserve Pearl characters
there are much more sophisticated land
use Avenues
preservable character preserved usable
huge pieces of land for habitat
certainly do you think those five to ten
acre Mansions are going to let you
cross-country ski through their backyard
no way but
I will
send your committee very specific
examples
and uh and also
um things that have been done that
appear to be meeting housing but in
essence I've had communities say we
allow multi-family zones and when you
overlay that zone map on a soil map
the multi-family zones are either
underwater or already developed that is
another
you know de jourive since de facto
exclusionary zoning
I won't take up your time I'll send you
the examples thank you
um any other questions representative
Reed
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question my question is going
to be for all the representatives of Elm
Grove
um but I just want to say first that I
so appreciate all the comments that you
all have made so far
um I'm so happy that obviously to the
extent You're Building affordable
housing but I think you're echoing
everything that we've already heard on
our committee which is on a bipartisan
basis and I I don't want to speak for
the whole committee but I would say
nearly unanimous opinion that these
exclusionary zoning is unethical and is
the the culprit for a lot of our ills
um my question and just for my
background I grew up in Section 8
housing I my whole life I've been a
tenant so I uh I was offended not that
you were saying it but the things that
you were conveying that other people
think about
affordable housing tenants in
specifically section innate tenants if
your car isn't up to Snuff you must be a
bad person kind of thinking is of deeply
offensive to me and yes we can do things
about the town
um we can we can tell the town what they
can and cannot do and this does seem to
cut across regardless of party line as
you pointed out both Hanover and Windham
have similar problems so it's not about
it's not a partisan issue my question
which is for all of you is the one of
quality and I don't mean the quality in
terms of what the community thinks and
facades and things like that I'm getting
to the quality for the tenants
themselves because I want to I want to
be assured that when we are helping
developers build what they call
Affordable housing that they are
actually providing good quality housing
and I mean housing quality both in terms
of Maintenance of the units but also
service to the tenants when you manage
your properties so for full disclosure
to of the committee members myself and
representative De Lorenzo are from
Newmarket Elm Grove recently acquired a
property in New Market last year a
senior home center and I've been working
with them I've met with them I can't
even tell you how many times at least on
a monthly but sometimes a weekly basis
for the multiple issues that that
property has had just a few of them for
months and months there was a leak in a
central hallway that we started to joke
was the original Wadley Falls the name
of the the place is Wadley Falls we have
one tenant who only has one leg who has
multiple accessibility issues in her
unit as well as the property in general
we've had people break into and also
enter into tenants units without
permission is there is there a question
yes the question is as I've already said
how do we know that quality will be met
both in terms of service and I'm happy
to afford the emails that I've sent to
Elm Grove about these issues to the
entire committee how do we know that
these issues will be met how do we know
that we will have quality what are the
restrictions that we can have or
guarantees we can have in place to make
sure that yes we will do everything we
can to help you develop affordable
housing but that has to be quality
housing that is my question it's open to
all of you
yeah so
um on the construction side uh
there are numerous requirements put in
place by New Hampshire housing uh when
you're going through their construction
process they have a entire uh
construction handbook manual on building
standards uh
Equity of amenities between units and
it's quite thorough and I will say it
it's it essentially
creates housing that's equivalent in my
view to the quality of market rate
construction
I wish you would argue sometimes goes
beyond what people do for market rate
construction I'll turn it over to Chris
in a second but from the ongoing
management
there are also
numerous inspections and housing
standards that you have to meet that
fire exceed what's required in market
rate housing HUD react inspections Mor
reviews
maybe you could take the floor on that
for a second Chris
sure I feel the need to answer directly
to what Miss Reed said
you know we purchased a property that
was 15 years old
15 years old and um it had been
professionally managed prior to us and
it had its fair share of problems when
we when we when we took over management
a leaky pipe in a hallway which was part
of a heating system
and uh in order to repair that situation
we would have to replace all of the
heating pipes in a hallway and uh do
that of course by doing that we have to
shut the heat down to the end to the
entire property to do it it's a big
project and um you know you have to go
through you have to go through the the
steps to find a quality contractor to do
it and make sure you're lining it up and
it's in a in a way that it'll get done
in a reasonable period of time and we
did that and you know I met with all of
the residents at Wadley Falls and
representative Reed was there and
representative De Lorenzo was there and
representative Michael Cahill was there
and the director of the local Housing
Authority was there and I stood before
all of the residents and answered and
discussed all of their questions and
told them what I was going to do on the
property and did exactly what we said we
not only did we did we repair the water
issue we've later on found that our zone
valve and isolation valves in every
single Unit were corroded and at one
point we tried to change his own valve
which is what gets the heat to the unit
we shut off the isolation valve to that
unit and it burst and it burst glycol
water from the heating system into
somebody's apartment
we couldn't have that happen again and
so what we had to do was go in and
replace every isolation valve in 57
apartments and every zone valve in 57
apartments in the winter
and turn the heat off and provide space
heaters in order to get that project
done
it took two days for each building to do
it and it was very very challenging but
it got done we also promised to install
we heard from residents when we took
over that they would lose heat in the
middle of winter when the electricity
would go out because it was all it was
all connected to the you know the
obviously it's one heating system for
the whole building we went and the
stalled owner with without having to two
generators to generate to run
electricity for both buildings in order
to make sure that at the very minimum
the common hallways and the heating
system would not do not turn off we
spent a tremendous amount of money on
this property we found during the
process that the residents were upset
about a lot of things when we took over
management things that had been you know
Legacy problems on the property that
hadn't been taken care of and we've gone
through and
really addressed everything but there
are a handful of residents at this
property particularly who who seems to
not want to be satisfied with anything
anything we do and we understand that
that's kind of the nature of the
business that we're in
um this resident with with an amp this
amputee resident
um
came to us asking us for a new shower to
be installed in her apartment what we
did was we offered her to move into an
available Ada apartment that uh that
already had that shower and she she
didn't want that we held that unit for
three months trying to convince her to
take that unit and she didn't take that
unit it has since been
taken on as a case by Elliot Berry who
I've been I've known for you know 10
years and worked well with and we've me
and him have been working on on that
solution he's told me not to do anything
in that unit until he I hear back from
him and I'm in regular contact with him
so I I don't feel in any way that the
residents at Wadley Falls are are being
mistreated or living in substantive
conditions thank you I appreciate it
you're not on trial so I appreciate you
answering the question and yeah that's
great um are there any other questions
for
um Elm Grove
or if there's anything else you can
contribute regarding
um regulations or anything we can do on
the state level to alleviate I did want
to speak to the management side so you
have problem issues obviously developing
affordable housing with nibis and which
we've spoken a lot about and of course
we have plenty of zoning zoning
challenges and Wetland challenges and
fire department challenges and then you
have obviously construction costs
challenges and and all of the things
that this committee knows about
the only affordable housing programs
that really exists anymore are the
low-income housing tax credit program
which is an IRS program that's that's
administered by Hud and by in in New
Hampshire's case New Hampshire housing
um you know you you you apply for and
receive tax credits which you which you
sell to an equity investor and that
brings Equity into the property that you
otherwise wouldn't have and allows you
to build a property that has rental
rates that are based on generally 60
area median income but they can they can
come averaging where you can you can
have set-asides for people that in the
20 area median income so that's somebody
making sixteen thousand dollars a year
all the way up to 80 and everything in
between by 10 basically
um it's a really interesting interesting
program
but to work with with New Hampshire
Housing and to and to manage a tax
credit property you have to have certain
expertise not every manager or property
developer would be approved to manage a
property like this there has to be
experiences certifications
um there's a there's a a good deal of
bureaucracy and compliance oversight
annual inspections you know we we have
our properties inspected annually by
um
HUD through react inspections file
reviews by New Hampshire housing if we
have Section 8 tenants then we have
section 8 voucher holder inspections
that are that are happening
um we have it and correct me if I'm
wrong those Section 8 voucher
inspections are property wide right they
in some cases they have to look at like
the stairs everywhere yeah they're going
to look at common areas common areas
okay they might in a property like
Wadley Falls where there's two buildings
they might just be looking at the one
building that the person but like the
parking lot like all that yeah the
stairs they're going to look for all of
any issues with life safety okay
um so there there's that and then we
have our annual Financial audits which
delve also into into compliance and then
we have a requirement to do annual 100
unit inspections as well so there's a
lot of people that are looking at these
at these units and and you know so
there's a lot of repairs and maintenance
happening all the time to to address
those issues but to if you
to build and develop and manage
affordable housing even on the
management side there's a certain amount
of expertise that's required you have to
have hot approval you have to have New
Hampshire housing approval you have to
have certifications in the management of
low-income housing tax credits you have
to have a an infrastructure within your
your company to manage that so A
compliance director people that
understand how to process these files
there's a tremendous amount of reporting
that we have to do either on a monthly
quarterly or annual basis so it's it's
it's difficult
it's worthwhile doing that's why that's
why we do it but not every person every
developer of real estate is going to be
wanting to develop affordable housing
because it's difficult it's a niche and
and if you get that experience and you
have the have those certifications and
you have the infrastructure built to to
do it then it's a lot easier but I I
imagine a lot of developers don't even
go into the go into it and in New
Hampshire there are only a handful of
experienced low-income housing tax
credit property management companies in
the first place that would provide third
party management I I can only think of
three and we're we're one of them I
imagine you would have to have a huge
infrastructure to manage that anyway
it's more you know so the cost of
managing affordable housing is higher
than than the cost of managing market
rate housing okay are there other
questions oh representative
I guess my question is how much higher
what what is like
um can you give me a ballpark figure of
like like cost per unit let's say of
market rate
um management versus cost
per per unit of affordable rate is it
like 20 more is it 50 more
not 50.
I mean
I'll I'll take that because I think it's
it's it's a multi-layered question
you've got there what what does it cost
it definitely costs more to staff the
additional compliance paperwork uh
maintenance needs that are there I would
say that's in the 20 to 25 percent more
range however
the lack of competition in the
affordable housing management world if
you don't manage for yourself there's a
few few options out there and I think
that also drives up the price right not
necessarily the cost but the price so if
you're a developer who doesn't
do your own management
you may be
forced into paying more for management
than you otherwise would in a more
competitive market
does that make sense so in that case the
I don't I don't want to necessarily go
into too many specifics there because
it's it's a small world but uh it there
there's not a lot of if you if you're a
developer that owns a property and you
don't do interim management and it's and
it's affordable as a land use
restriction on it you don't have a lot
of options the cost of that compliance
and the oversight is there if you have a
react inspection the HUD comes in and
looks at every everything they look at
every latch every hinge everything so
therefore there comes a laundry list of
of repairs to be made and then you do
your unit inspections and the same thing
happens and then Section 8 inspections
and the same same thing happens so you
know there the maintenance costs are
higher because
um you're you're required to respond to
those those inspection reports when they
come out can I ask specifically about I
know we have HUD right but we don't have
any control over HUD so can I ask
specifically
what on the state level
is a regulation or redundancy or
something that maybe this committee can
look further into maybe a requirement by
uh Des or you know a code enforcement
requirement or or or something that you
know this committee can look at
specifically so this was something that
recently came to our attention
um
through New Hampshire Housing Finance
the
Section 8 Voucher Program apparently
there is a designation that the state
agency can get to help streamline some
of the
regulatory
bureaucratic oversight that comes with
the Section 8 voucher and we're just
finding out about it now that they have
applied to have this which would help
all property owners who would accept
Section 8 vouchers to uh to make that an
easier process I wonder if there are
other ways that the state Housing
Authority could
get a
delegated authority from HUD
to perform one inspection that meets all
the requirements rather than multiple
and have to deal with
two different agencies versus one
of the headache and pain is
just dealing with the online site I hate
to even bring it up but that's that
yeah it's it's a it's a Vortex
just dealing with anything we would have
to do to deal with if there's some
technology some website that we have to
use with HUD it was it was built in 1986
and it's extremely you have to get mail
to get the password change I mean it's
it's challenging um I know yeah no
that's challenging so this I think I
just spoke with d poulette
uh about um I think it's called move to
work
don't quote me on that but it's a it's a
it's a beta test program for the Section
8 voucher program and there's some
really interesting things in there um
there are incentives for landlords to
accept Section 8 vouchers
um there are
um some changes to how they do
inspections when they do inspections so
they for example on the light tech
property they would only do unit
inspections every three years so there's
a bunch of kind of these changes that
are supposed to take some of the
red tape out of being involved in the
program and to make it a little little a
better experience for landlords and you
can see on the New Hampshire housing
side they recently it's a small thing
but it's it's actually a big thing they
recently said you no longer have to send
in quarterly Financial reports
there's all kinds of little touch points
that we deal with with New Hampshire
Housing and compliance that could be uh
I guess polished down a little bit to
make it real easier the January of every
year is is crazy we have we have to do a
full on
under the hood the financial
um Financial audit for all of these
types of properties and it it takes our
our accounting department our finance
department the month to so it's all that
they think about for an entire month and
at the same time we have
um all of these uh file review Mor's
they call them where we have to where
New Hampshire housing comes to the
property and looks through files and
does inspections and that sort of thing
and those all happen around the same as
well
um so I mean there are a lot of touch
points where they things could be
smoothed out I think I I could provide a
recommendation
but I don't want to make any assumptions
that New Hampshire housing even has to
change the ability to change those rules
and I will say if if they do not have
the ability to change these rules we do
um I would I I would I mean our job is
to solicit recommendations so anything
you have to recommend please send to the
committee sure okay representative Gibbs
thank you
um again this is going to basically have
to come out as a statement
um
okay I'm not arguing
um with
everybody's understanding of the misery
of bureaucratic requirements
um in dealing with HUD I probably know
that better than anybody here
um
there is one thing that that we all have
to keep in mind and that is that where
are these requirements come from and I'm
not saying that they can't be
streamlined because I know in a lot of
cases they can be and should be
um but where they come from is from the
fact that what we're dealing with is the
expenditure of taxpayer money and when
we're dealing um either with direct
federal or state subsidies or with for
instance tax credit construction which
is indeed pretty much all of the
low-income housing Construction in
recent years it is still taxpayer money
because we're one entity gets a tax
credit somebody else is making up for it
so it's it's taxpayer money and
therefore there are requirements created
by Congress
for
justifying how taxpayer money is being
spent and those requirements are
intended to make sure that it is being
spent properly now
whether
the reporting and so forth can be
streamlined
I don't think anybody would argue that
that would that would be a bad thing
it's just that we have to keep in mind
where this comes from it comes from the
fact that we're talking about the
expenditure of taxpayer money
if I may respond to that and also kind
of draw it back up to a higher level I
absolutely agree that that type of
oversight is warranted and and required
and understandable
um I think over time it's that creep of
every additional task
and redundant requirement in many cases
that just adds to the cost at the end of
the day
I think really everything about the
housing issue boils down to the more it
costs to build
an apartment
the less Apartments will have right just
supply and demand so
there's no Silver Bullet in this whole
discussion there's got to be multiple
avenues that everyone every stakeholder
has to look at to reduce barriers
barriers or costs time is cost
um
redundant requirements are cost and if
we can look at how we lower the overall
cost to build housing
the economy will take care of it we'll
build more because the demand's there
the supplies the supply is not keeping
up
and you know that economics 101 right
with the supply demand curve where it
where it meets that's the price that's
why I rent so high that's why single
family construction uh prices are so
high
if I may transition a little bit to to
the construction costs and some ideas
there
um
construction costs a lot of it's going
to be outside of our control right
uh Lumber comes from Canada from other
parts of the country appliances come
from overseas vinyl comes from factories
in Texas and it's it's it's a global
supply chain uh it's hard to affect that
but I think what we do have the ability
to affect a little bit more is our labor
um there was recently in Ohio put into
place
full Reciprocity for all uh trade
licensing
electricians Plumbing HVAC gas uh I
thought it was an incredible move for
that state to do because now Ohio is
open for business if you were a plumber
you don't have to go through another
course another test and you want to move
to Ohio New Hampshire could do something
I think that's a pretty easy thing to do
well and the governor did bring that up
in the budget address as one of his
priorities and I think that's that is
something that bipartisan as bipartisan
agreement good that that would help a
lot labor costs has gone up incredibly
there there's there's a shortage of
licensed trades people I think in every
area
um
the seeds of that were sown probably the
last 30 years where you know I think the
American kind of culture was go to
college go to Liberal Arts degree or
whatever and go that route and and the
trades were
you know minimized or look look down
upon in a lot of cases that I think the
pendulum swung a bit now the trade
schools as I understand are full they're
over capacity it's great it's going to
take time to rebuild that so in the in
the interim we need to attract
great qualified trades people from you
know outside our borders as much as we
can
um maybe there's incentives I know other
states have offered you know relocate
and we'll help you with the down payment
or something like that there's a lot of
that was happening with the dislocation
in covid but I I don't know all the
ideas I'm sure you're going to probably
hear a lot of them but bringing more
workers to New Hampshire
will help us build the housing that they
can then live in right right
that's a big thing thank you
representative Conkey thank you Mr
chairman
um briefing through some of the
information that you folks gave and see
they're you folks or someone earlier
talked about downsizing of units getting
costs down I see you use a term in the
literature here of mini Flats micro
units so could you just tell me what
size that kind of square feet are you
looking at in those projects and and do
each of those units have have kitchens
or are they sharing kitchens yeah so
one particular project we did in
Manchester was that the flats at Hanover
common
um it was previously a drug and alcohol
rehab facility so there were small rooms
in there we were able to develop the
concept was mini Flats um these are Stu
small studio apartments with modular
Furniture so a couch that turns into a
bed a desk that turns into a bed with
both kitchens although cooktops and a
convection microwave instead of a full a
full oven and you know these are nicely
appointed granite countertops this is a
market rate these are market rate units
they're the smaller ones were are 280
square feet
um so they're they're quite small and
and you know everybody thought all the
Millennials are gonna you know eat this
up but it was recent divorcees that that
filled the building up at first
um these units though I guess the point
was these units we were able to build
for you know whatever it costs we were
able to rent them for at the time of the
lease up around 950 a month for a nice
apartment with nice amenities with a gym
with a cafe downstairs and an outdoor
area so you could get the same thing
that Brady Sullivan was doing in the
mills for a fraction of the cost of
course also a fraction of size and the
turnover there is fairly high so people
don't stay for very long they'll move
into something more like a more
reasonable size I don't believe that
that type of housing is what we would
develop in terms of affordable housing
but it is it is a valid uh there is a
lot of demand for spare for for studio
apartments
um and and it's a valid way to bring
affordable housing into the community
it's a way to create some measure of
affordability within market rate now I
think
that goes into the to the density in
Manchester they were supportive of doing
a really dense uh Redevelopment of
existing property
it was a huge success there there was no
parking actually at the building that we
were scared about that initially and uh
what we found
over and over again in Manchester and in
Concord is that
especially for kind of urban infill
Redevelopment of existing properties
that might be partially vacant or
decrepit is that that model can work
really well and it does provide
residence and option uh different than
the two thousand dollar 2200 a month two
bedroom apartment for the outskirts of
town it's not under the tax credit
program but it
does cost a lot less per month I think
it's a really cool concept almost like
like
just an upgrade from like college dorm
you know like right right when you're
like leaving you have your own bedroom
but maybe shared spaces in some ways
some way one of our employees graduated
from college came to work for us lived
there for a year and a half then as his
income went up you know I got promoted
he went to a bigger place it's great
it's a great place for people who are in
a transitional period or an upwardly
mobile period in there you know perfect
representative McConkey all set yeah
okay
um representative Delorenzo I I like
that concept of the mini sweeps or mini
units um is there any like common area
where a person who lived in one of those
many units could
say that they work from home Associated
office space for folks as an option in
in that particular case there's a
there's a cafe the restoration Cafe
um in Manchester uh when when they close
up at night they they pull the garage
door down over there over their counter
and leave all of their dining area uh
open to and outdoor area open to the
residence so they residents then can
come in and have an event or or you're
right work down there and be around
other people
um I feel that that concept regardless
of what we did at that property is one
that you would you would always want to
try to do because
it does provide that value of space some
Elbow Room if you were to just stack a
lot of 280 square foot apartments with
no common space they would not rent very
well I don't think right they wouldn't
hold up well yeah over time it would
turn into a
you know what you might typically think
of as a rooming house and
a trouble that might come with that
for five years this property has has
maintained itself as a is it attractive
nice apartment complex with um you know
upwardly mobile people moving in and out
on a regular basis and it it works I
don't know that it works in every
Community right or how many of them
thank you
um and I I suppose the to take after my
seat mate this might be a little bit
more of a statement but I I do commend
the idea of smaller you know doing
whatever kind of like what the previous
people said
um you know everything
I like the idea of having smaller units
but I want us to hold in our minds but
also one of the reasons I put into my
Adu Bill to increase the size of adus is
because 750 square feet just really
isn't long-term sustainable for most
people to live in so if we're looking
for sustainable housing in terms of
keeping people in communities long term
we need to have
um more reasonable I think was how Chris
said it more reasonably sized uh places
as well as the smaller and I have a
convection uh microwave oven that I I
and I don't use my regular oven so I
holy wholeheartedly support the idea of
smaller stuff but I want us to keep in
mind that we also have to do things that
are going to be sustainable long term I
think that's the key though right
everything yeah every ad user are you're
not going to solve the housing crisis
with adus but not that it is low but
there's a there
if I own a home where I can have an Adu
it's there's a lot my mother my mother's
aging there's there's an opportunity to
bring her in there or or eventually use
it as a way to augment my um my mortgage
adus are great and they should be
um micro units you know of course you're
gonna have communities that say no your
unit can't be bigger than or smaller
than
700 square feet but then that takes out
all the 500 and 280 square foot homes
that will will help people if you look
over in you know Japan where the people
are living in pods that's an air I'm not
saying we need to do that here but you
know everything is should be on the
table
there's a concept like you have a
stronger Community within your town but
also within the building when you have
like the smaller units and let people
decide where they right where and how
they want to to live yeah I'm sure the
person that moves into the flats at 280
square feet this isn't the ice some
people think it's the greatest thing
yeah but at some point they it's it's
right for them at some point it's not
right for them there's always somebody
else that it's right for and yeah and it
allowed us to put double the units into
a building that we otherwise would
normally traditionally done as soon as
you restrict to minimums or maximums
you're you're lowering the overall
potential pool of Housing Development
right the market will respond to demand
so if somebody wants to move from the
750 to 1200 and then to a single family
home
the market will see that they'll see the
demand and it will try to develop
housing it's when you restrict you say
no you can't build these
the market can't react it can't respond
it can't build that housing and the risk
all falls on you know someday micro
units won't be popular anymore and we'll
have an empty building and we're going
to have to redevelop our building and
put in half the number of units and or
when it was built it was four or five
units this this property was originally
a private complex with five units I
lived in Japan three years so I was glad
you brought that up but it's it's uh it
I don't think it'll ever not be a good
thing but yeah just wanting to Encompass
everyone's needs and people's needs are
different all right well in in the
effort to close this up I'm gonna let
representative McConkey go represent
yokella let you guys close out and then
we're going to break for lunch
thank you gentlemen the Manchester unit
that you spoke about is not shown could
you just tell me that property name
again oh that's called the flats at
Hanover common the flats nh.com
um what you're looking at is the uh the
Star Building and the kirsage which is
over by um what was White Mountain
Coffee that's right the curious so I
just want to bring up the point the
community or to the committee that the
mix is really important to talk about
subdivisions is not totally the answer I
brought up in earlier conversations
there's retailers that they're what
they're paying for rent isn't or what
they're paying for wages isn't
tremendous and having the ability to
House people in your building
I think his Merit so I think I think
it's a mix of everything thank you Joan
thank you Mr chairman for the course
representative
I just felt the need to disagree with my
my seat mate over here because
um I my house is it's not even an
apartment and it's less than 700 square
feet and I've lived in it for seven
years and I'm not planning on leaving
anytime soon and so I think that it's
um allowing opportunities for for
someone like me that doesn't
understands that property that if I got
a bigger house I would have to pay more
taxes
that and and am able to live in a
smaller area that that those needs are
being able to be met by being allowed to
be built and not having a minimum
um that
um and so I do I do think
um one of the things that we might
consider is is not is in the Adu
legislation
um saying that they're you know you
can't have a minimum like you can say
maybe set a maximum as far as of as that
but maybe removing the minimum
requirement might be some or uh the
option for a minimum requirement
um might be something that the committee
might be open to or just in general
talking about the Adu issues and and
um allowing developers
um to be able to
have those different types of units like
maybe a 200 square foot unit and a
thousand square foot unit it's going to
be you know I'm not going to be having
four kids in my house but
right and so
but uh yeah so I just wanted to say that
as we don't just well I mean she said
that some people under use we were
saying something about people under 700
square feet might might not want to live
in it for more than a year and that's
what I was I was saying opposing
well
you might be surprised to know that I
lived in a 24 by 24 so 600 square foot
home for 11 years by by an experience in
Japan
well and I I want to thank you gentlemen
for presenting to us
um I do want any feedback you can at all
that we can do on the state level with
agencies
um any roadblocks you're looking at we
understand there's a local control issue
we get it
um I guess but that's not something we
really necessarily want to touch here we
want to see what we can do on the state
level
um you've given us some good ideas but
anything else you think of please please
please amola committee
yeah we'll absolutely follow up with a
few of those studies that we mentioned
to put a bit of a challenge out there I
would say
it would be
bold and I think needed for
the state legislature to take on a
little bit of that local control without
stripping it away completely right
that's what makes New Hampshire special
but
uh holding local municipalities
accountable to as Steve was saying the
Constitution right uh when it goes
beyond
Beyond The Pale uh that's where I think
the state does have a goal so okay A
little bit of a challenge we need the
help
thank you Bill so it's out there yeah
yes and I think the uh the state has
done a good job of having all of our
state agencies be a little bit more
customer friendly and provide a little
bit better level of customer service
we're going to try to do the same thing
to get the municipalities to be on board
with that as well
um I think a lot of it comes from their
ignorance of uh the zoning regulations
and the application thereof and uh yeah
I think this is the opportunity for us
to come up with a multi-faceted approach
regulation Improvement zoning
Improvement uh compliance with the
federal uh with our federal overlords as
far as the money goes all of these
things I think will make a big
difference and let us all get back to
doing what we do providing housing for
people here in New Hampshire
well thank you and with that we're on
the committee is going to break until
promptly at one o'clock in presentation
um starting at one okay thank you thank
you appreciate it thanks
see
good afternoon
this is going to be tricky I'm getting
I'm just getting old enough that I um
I can't I can't see you without my
glasses and I can't see my paper with
sunglasses so this is going to be
interesting welcome to the club
yeah it is a little dangerous in the
stairs actually
um so yes my name is John McKinney I'm
the policy director at New Hampshire
legal assistance thank you for inviting
me today to speak with you
I um spoiler alert we do not build
housing
we do not address Supply and that is the
the kind of um
the direction I've received from the
members of the committee is to focus
really more on that so I'm gonna come at
it from a slightly I'm going to try to
just tell you a little bit about what we
do and I'm going to tell you like one or
two maybe things that you might be able
to to do but mainly I'm gonna yield my
time to my colleagues in the back who
have a lot more data and information
about
from New Hampshire Housing and housing
action New Hampshire so
um New Hampshire legal assistance is a
non-profit Law Firm we provide free
legal help to low-income Granite Staters
we have five offices across the state
Berlin Claremont Portsmouth Manchester
and Concord and we provide legal
assistance in lots of different areas of
the law and not not just housing but
housing is our largest area practice
area so
um and that work really focuses on
preserving housing and preventing
homelessness
so one of our top priorities which we
heard a little bit about earlier is
preserving vouchers
vouchers take many years for folks to
get like I think five to seven years is
roughly
um typical
and those vouchers pay allow a tenant to
pay about 30 percent of their income
towards rent uh I'm kind of simplifying
things a little bit otherwise we get
really in the weeds really quickly but
um so if they lose that it's huge it's a
huge loss to them and to their entire
life I guess I would say in terms of
destabilizing a lot of different things
so
um it's also really hard to find an
apartment that will accept a voucher or
that you know is a suitable for a
voucher
um so we actually have a situation where
people wait years and years to get a
voucher right now and then eight about
18 each year lose those vouchers because
they can't find somewhere to use it so
um that's kind of so when someone comes
to us with a I'm going to lose my
voucher it's a really high priority for
us because it's it's a Lifeline for them
um generally we're talking about oh I
think about
60 or maybe a little higher
um of voucher holders also have
disabilities so it's a um like I said
it's it really does kind of have a
ripple effect in their lives if they
lose that and so and it also has a lot
of value you know to the in terms of
uh stabilizing someone's housing and
it's over a long term versus like you
know one month's rent or something like
that so that's why we we've prioritized
that we also do work to prevent
evictions
um we all know I think just it pretty
common sense I think that once someone
is homeless it's incredibly difficult to
get them rehoused it's also very
expensive
um to get them rehoused and
um so if we can avoid evictions that's
something we try to do we
we are seeing a lot of
um
the trends lately in terms of those
cases are related to rent increases and
renovations
um and it's just really hard in this
market to find an alternative place to
live so
um as I'm sure others have already
talked about and we'll talk about we
have less than a we have I think it's
point three percent vacancy rate at this
point somewhere between 0.3 and 0.5 at
any time
um so it is
just a really tough environment for
someone to find alternative housing
uh on short order especially and with
limited income so the ways that we do
this work we do have eviction clinics
where we particularly in Manchester and
Nashua where they have kind of eviction
cases all scheduled on the same day
um it was obviously a lot easier to do
that work or make an impact and avoid
prevent evictions when we had the
emergency rental assistance money to for
folks to be able to make their landlords
whole
um
we also work on the homeowners
assistance fund which helps to prevent
foreclosures we help people access
property tax exemptions or and things
like that that might that they're
eligible for
um so that's kind of in a nutshell uh
where you know kind of what we do
related to housing and
um I think the biggest thing that this
this body or this specific committee but
also just the body in general can do is
to really think hard about legislation
that comes before you in terms of what
its impact might be on the housing
um environment that we're currently in
um so for example trying not to further
destabilizing destabilize housing
um
for example I know that this group isn't
necessarily interested in in additional
landlord-tenant restrictions
um so or regulation but
um we we would argue that you know there
are lots of ways to evict someone we
have a very rob you know a very robust
um
set of options for folks to to evict
someone if someone is a problem
um obviously if someone's not paying
their rent if someone is destructive all
the all these different ways to evict
someone
um so anything we don't necessarily need
more ways to make it easier to evict
anyone that's one thing we would say
and then
um
the another area I guess where we would
be happy to work with folks on is is one
of the conversations that came up before
the break was about
um you know ways to incentivize
landlords to participate in
the HUD programs and streamlining those
processes as much as possible
um I would all that also goes to another
legislative
option I guess or that one of the things
that was discussed earlier was also
um the stigma
um around different uh vouchers in the
or or different people essentially
um that require housing in our state
um
and maybe one way to address that would
be
um and this is there's a bill currently
being considered around housing about
your discrimination
um if you let someone in the door right
and you get to know the person as an
individual
um you might find that that on a
one-on-one basis is really goes a long
way in terms of destigmatizing or
dispelling kind of the myths that exists
about folks that
um might have a housing voucher for
example so
that is I said I'd be quick I tried to
stay to the
areas of Interest
so I try to follow directions well I I
appreciate it a lot thank you for
obliging us
um uh representative McConkey
thank you Mr chairman uh Dawn educate me
a little please
um vouchers when you say vouchers and
those being distributed through your
department or is that we do not
distribute the vouchers at all no
so and the 30 if someone gets through
the system or is in line long enough and
they get this 30 percent is is is there
a cap on what the 70 percent on top of
that that total rent can accumulate
yes well just to clarifying twelve
hundred dollars a month yes there are
all kinds of regulations around what the
rent can be and that's one of the other
challenges to finding a suitable when I
mentioned is finding a suitable
apartment to use the voucher it's not
just about landlords willingness to
participate in the program it's also
about like the market rate of the rent
and all of those things and if you don't
mind
um it's and basically it's about 30
percent of the tenants income goes
towards rent and then the difference
okay is paid for by the voucher but I'm
gonna defer any more kind of granular
questions about that
Mr chairman is is are we talking Section
8 what's what's the term for what I'm
looking at yes section eight we actually
it's called housing Choice vouchers now
thank you so much representative Gibbs
um thank you um just in terms of the
distribution of vouchers um I can help a
little bit there
um uh housing vouchers are normally
distributed uh by local housing
authorities and some are also
distributed by state housing authorities
the funding comes from HUD to the state
housing authorities and to the local
housing authorities which then
distribute the vouchers and there are
HUD regulations
um uh in regard to uh rent which vary by
location in terms of the um uh housing
market in the location and there are
also other requirements
um in terms of uh
in terms of the housing itself right
yeah representative Broody okay thank
you Mr chairman you mentioned that you
help uh stop foreclosures how do you do
that well I don't personally do it we
have a couple of uh attorneys who work
on that project
um and it's really I you generally and
I'm happy to have provide more
information or have them come and speak
to you about it it it's generally folks
that have
um there's some sort of well it's a
similar program the the homeowners
assistance fund was set up um during
kova to help homeowners who've gotten
behind in their mortgages so that's
that's a temporary kind of funding
source that's available right now to
help people with their mortgages and
property taxes and utilities
um related to their home ownership and
then in terms of
um
previous prior to covid
um we've we've always had a I would say
like a foreclosure it's called our
foreclosure relief project and it has to
do with folks that have
uh we're not providing funding so it's
really just about
how to
um remedy a situation that's developed
between the actual mortgage company and
the individual and order to preserve
their housing sometimes it's about like
things like you know the statements the
mortgage mortgage got sold to some
another company and the person didn't
get the right information and the
payments weren't making it to the right
place like those kinds of things where
we're trying to work with the mortgage
between the
um
the homeowner and the mortgage
lender to address those kind of issues
so that they don't lose their home back
around 2007 and 2008 that was a big part
of my business helping people uh stay
out of foreclosures and they'd wind up
in shot sales maybe but at least it'd
keep them in your house for another six
months or a year or whatever but I I was
always thinking of
maybe in a banking commission or didn't
want to play ball with me at the time
where some of these people have
50 or 60 percent equity in their home
and they can't meet their payments
and the banks would foreclose and they
didn't care what they got for it because
it wasn't their money anyway just get it
off their books and I that was always a
sore in my side that people would lose a
lifetime of equity
in a bank that doesn't have a high so I
thought you might have we've definitely
that would that would be a way to keep
people from being homeless too and uh
yep absolutely that's one another way to
avoid homelessness for sure
representative De Lorenzo thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question Don could you tell me more
about the eviction clinics are those
held at court are they held they are
they are on the day of the hearing yes
they're they're um something new that we
set up during kova to respond to the
like
High number of evictions after
um
the eviction moratorium was lifted and
so we do we have it we have staff that
are there the day of and folks
as folks come in they can talk to one of
our attorneys we can also work with the
landlords to negotiate
um some sort of like either when there
were emergency rental assistance dollars
available
it was obviously much easier to you know
you could the the Caps were are also
often on site
um they were previously they're I think
for the most part they're no longer on
site
um because the the funding is not
available we're still doing the eviction
clinics but it makes just coming to an
agreement a little harder but yes
they're referring we were referring
folks right over to the Caps to if they
hadn't already applied or if they had
applied they just needed to sort out the
status of their application Etc they
could do that right on site and we could
negotiate with the landlords to try to
work out like whether it was like
extending their move out time so that
they could find another place to live or
things like that
may I follow up of course so um I'm
aware that Rockingham County does have
um yes money you're right rent do you
know of any of the other Counties have
some um Rockingham County is the only
one that has an application open at this
point I believe
um although maybe Ben might have more
information about that than I do as well
but
um
I believe there and there's some state
level money that's that's really being
um
targeted to folks that are already
currently getting assistance through
that program
um but that and that is finite and will
end for different households in the
upcoming months thank you
so I'm looking specifically at
um something I heard from Elm Grove that
was a
sort of a roadblock was the amount of
inspections that happen right and that
comes through you know whatever sort of
vouchers they get or you know um low
income housing tax tax credits things
like that they're subject to a a ton of
inspections
um
would there be a solution to maybe
streamline the inspection process so
that maybe they're only getting
inspected
once a year by person that's certified
to inspect for everything or like do you
have any feedback on that like something
we can do
um I think that's a great question and I
did hear him raise that issue before the
break
um and we would be happy to work with
with you on if there are explore ways if
there are ways to do that
um
I think it would be kind of a group a
group effort with folks here to me that
there's there's like different people
that inspect for different things and if
you just have one person that can
inspect for everything yeah it kind of
just like makes it way easier on it
every everybody yes I'm not I'm not I'm
not an expert or familiar with it you
know all of those rules and regs and how
the inspection process works so I
wouldn't want to comment too much on it
but I would just say that we'd be
willing to work with whoever to try to
figure out ways to streamline that
process
um that seems to make sense it would
help the developer or the property owner
but even the tenants so that they're not
letting people into their house
constantly in their home Mr chair well
one of the issues is that um your
funding sources have inspections too so
you know I could have a property with
low income insurance and tax credits
they'll do an inspection if it has had
money they'll do an inspection if I have
Federal Home Loan Bank
um as a mother T then um that mortgage
yard then that would require an
something to think about absolutely
there any other questions for Don
okay
yeah
um
go ahead well if you consider the uh the
residents of these properties getting a
seems like it might be a you know every
other month type of an inspection that
seems like an unnecessary intrusion and
perhaps a
Fourth Amendment violation in a class
all right well um with that I want to
welcome up
um Alyssa margolin from housing action
New Hampshire and Ben Frost from New
Hampshire
oh
okay perfect are we doing all three of
you or do you want to say Ben for some
we're special committee with special
rules
Mr chairman members of the committee for
the record my name is Alyssa margolin I
serve as director of housing action New
Hampshire I want to start by thanking
the chair and the members of this
committee for inviting us to present to
you today and I just I also want to
thank you for taking on this additional
role that I know you're spending your
Friday in addition to your the committee
duties you already have
um and the and the floor sessions that
you have in the house so so thank you
for for investing your time and trying
to address our housing crisis
um what we have planned for you in terms
of a presentation is I'm uh I serve as
director of the Statewide affordable
housing Coalition I'm going to tell you
very briefly about our advocacy then um
one of our members uh who serves as a
major developer of affordable housing in
the state we'll talk to you about what
it takes to get affordable housing built
in the state and then we're going to
leave the rest of our time for the
deputy executive director and chief
legal officer of our state Housing
Finance Authority Ben Frost
um who I think I saw Mr Lewis this
morning uh talk frequently about Ben not
only his um
depth and breadth of knowledge about
housing policy but also his planning
background his role as chair of the
Warner planning board
um and uh
and he's going to tell you about the
role of New Hampshire housing in the
state that I know representative Gibbs
just mentioned as well as a lot of the
data that could really help serve this
committee as you assess where you would
like to go in the policy proposals that
you would like to bring forward so
that's the plan so my part will be
pretty brief so housing action New
Hampshire is an advocacy Coalition I
spend a lot of time talking to you here
at the state house we focus at
improving state and federal policy so
everyone in New Hampshire has a place to
call home our members and I've handed
out a list of our members to you are
those who develop finance and manage
affordable housing properties and as I
said Robert torney's here he's one of
our members
um and also the public housing agency
homeless service providers and
Supportive Housing agencies so a lot of
the issues so we are your key Partners
in trying to build our way out of this
crisis and we applaud your focus on
addressing the supply issue because we
are very much experiencing a crisis
because of the lack of Supply so that's
who we are and this is a budget year and
so I've handed to you a presentation
that I've been giving about our
priorities there are many many housing
bills and we know that many people were
who are serving now in the legislature
talked with their constituents in their
communities about the housing crisis and
they have come to serve in this
legislative sessions with a lot of
proposals and there are a lot of bills
and a lot of them are very good
proposals but with a presentation I gave
you are kind of the major priorities of
our Coalition and one of those bills has
a lot to do with the supply issue and
that bill is in the Senate right now it
has a hearing on Tuesday and that is a
lot of the funding mechanisms and I know
that you're aware that and maybe I know
this is somewhat controversial but in
that body in that chamber they tend to
debate their funding bills table them
and then include them in their version
of the budget of nhb1 and hb2 and then
it comes back to you in Committee of
conference so this committee will have
you know an understanding of the funding
proposals that are in Senator innis's
Bill and that's in that presentation
there's also a new home ownership fund
being proposed that would be
administered by Ben shop
and our members are interested in
getting into starter home and a more
affordable home ownership opportunities
and that's Senator rashardi's Bill that
had its uh hearing last week and in its
policy Committee in Commerce got a 5-0
out of pass recommendation go to the
floor and then go to Senate finance my
guess is that also probably if it if it
passes would probably also be tabled
um and come to you through the budget
Bill and um the other major
policy bill that we're very focused on
also came up in your committee this
morning and that is a housing Champions
proposal and this is an Innovative
partnership between the state and
municipalities and a number of business
interests have come together including
the business and industry Association
the bankers the Realtors who I know you
heard from this morning restaurant and
Lodging Association and the auto dealers
and the municipal Association and us
to move forward a proposal that your
chairman worked on in 2019 as part of
the governor's housing task force that
is what would it look like to
incentivize
municipalities to respond and reward
those who are ready to meet this Market
need so that's the big overview of the
policy and what we do and so now I think
I would just um like to give the
microphone over to our member Rob oh go
take my seat in the back
um and Robert we'll talk to you like
where the
um bricks meet the mortar so to speak
and act what it takes to get something
built and then you'll hear from Ben and
then I'm happy to pop back up if you
have any questions specifically for me
is that okay
that's okay perfect thank you Alyssa
thank you Alyssa thank you very much uh
as Alyssa mentioned my name is Robert
Turney and I'm the executive director of
neighborworks Southern New Hampshire uh
private non-profit Community Development
Corporation with a focus on providing
affordable housing we've been around for
about 30 years I've been the director
there for now for 18 years and over
those over that period of time we've
developed over 500 units of affordable
rental housing
and assisted literally thousands of
families purchase a home of their own
and so very familiar with the
development approval process in many of
the jurisdictions in New Hampshire
Southern New Hampshire as well as the
financing and mechanism that it takes to
develop affordable housing in New
Hampshire and so I'm very pleased that
we have this committee and that housing
is on everyone's agenda because it's
really really an important issue and
really a challenging one for us
um I'll begin by saying that
we have um I I have made lots of
presentations to a lot of different
communities over the years planning
boards Town councils Boards of Selectmen
Economic Development task Forces school
boards even uh anyone in a town who will
listen about the particular need for
affordable housing in their community
and how they can how we can help that
town address their challenges and their
needs and I've always had sort of this
recipe or formula that I followed and
said if if we can come into the town and
have access to density
to to achieve enough density to make a
project feasible which would most likely
rely on having access to public water
and public sewer we can go to New
Hampshire housing the Federal Bank as
was mentioned earlier the Community
Development Finance Authority a handful
of funding sources and we can make a
project happen in your community and and
it can be affordable I I can't rely on
that recipe anymore the last few years
just the costs us associated with
developing anything have just gone so
high Sky High that even with density
even with free land sometimes it's still
very very challenging to have the end
product become affordable I've always
said because we use the low income
housing tax credit to finance what we do
they don't sell low income two by fours
at Lowe's we pay the same for building
materials as everybody else and so
there's not a difference in quality in
the end product and so we really do have
to
um you know maintain a good quality
project to be able to last and be
durable for a long period of time and uh
and maintain a good quality of life for
the families that live there and so
our organization is at a very successful
track record starting in the city of
Manchester we are also in the city of
Nashua and we've developed projects in
the towns of Goffstown and Hooksett and
Londonderry Amherst and Merrimack and
just to give you a perspective of where
costs have gone in the last couple of
years we
um our last project was in the town of
Merrimack and our total development cost
was around 260
000 per unit all in land infrastructure
soft costs architecture engineering
construction financing fees everything
and that was our total development cost
per unit today
our construction costs are over 260 000
per unit not including the land the soft
cost so our our costs of everyone's
costs Construction and building and
development costs have just gone up
exponentially over the last couple of
years so that's what contributes to that
formula of
access to density water and sewer just
not being feasible because prices are
for everything or have just gone up so
uh so much so exponentially and so it
makes it really challenging without
resources and so I'm pleased that the
state has been able to put funding
through the advocacy work of housing
action New Hampshire and the support of
support of the legislature into the um
real estate transfer tax program uh to
fund the affordable housing trust fund
that's administered by New Hampshire
housing as uh you know for for many many
years I'll tell you I would go to
national conferences housing conferences
and when State organizations would talk
about how much their state cut their
budget I would say well our state didn't
cut a budget because we don't have a
budget to start with so it's it's it's
quite helpful now to have a budget of
State support that that goes into
affordable housing
as far as our development approval
process
um I can tell you it varies widely from
Community to community
in some jurisdictions
um there's there's good coordination
from a planning and land use standpoint
and I can say for firsthand that in some
jurisdictions it's a big challenge there
are some pretty big gaps between
um
written codes and written ordinances and
and what is expected of the developer
and so it can take an enormous amount of
time and money to get through the
planning approval process you know I can
hire an architect to design a building
that
is code compliant and I can hire an
architect an engineer to design a
subdivision or development plans that
meet the spirit of the ordinance and we
submit them to the town and then the
town comes back and says but we want
this we want this we want this and we
want this and those aren't necessarily
in their ordinance but they're going to
make us do them and there's often times
very little
uh
I would say there's no consideration as
to what cost that may impose on the
development project
oftentimes the the the justification or
the reasoning if for those additional
changes are Public Safety
and my response is you know well if your
codes are insufficient you should update
your codes not just add to them on the
spot and so I will say that I was a
supporter of the creation of the housing
appeals board a few years ago not
because I want to use it because I don't
I've never had an opportunity to use it
and I hope I never do but
um I was a proponent of it for for that
reason because there are many times
where I feel like we are unjustifiably
being held to a standard that
um is beyond
be beyond the law but beyond the
requirement uh set by the jurisdiction
and so
and I can't say that this is true in
every single Community because it varies
widely from town to town and so I often
say to individuals who
quote back to me that it's about local
control I oftentimes feel like local
control in some communities boils down
to one person and one individual and
that one individual has all the control
to make and to dictate what we can do
for our projects and so it can
oftentimes be a challenge so I know that
the I know that there has been a toolbox
legislation to help
um
improve our uh the training and
education that goes along with being in
a in a land use decision process and so
um anything to help I guess educate and
inform uh local bodies local committees
about the process I'm all for it and
like I said I I spent many of my first
years at neighborworks because our our
history our history was working uh
predominantly in the city of Manchester
and so to get into some of the more
Suburban towns it took a lot of
education and information because if you
can imagine
um a high density
um multi-family project in the city of
Manchester that's not necessarily going
to work in some of the Suburban towns so
I did need to spend a lot of time
speaking to the volunteer committees the
planning staff whoever would listen to
me uh in these surrounding towns about
what affordable housing is how we can go
about delivering it and how it's not
necessarily a bad thing for your
community it's really an essential tool
that the market isn't addressed and so
they don't want to drone on too long I
want to give Ben a chance to to talk but
I would certainly entertain any
questions or if you had anything
specific that you'd like to ask me so
thank you for coming to speak with us my
question is on um there's a lot of
improvements that were made through the
community toolbox Bill last year some
got through through a committee
conference
um I believe Ben canson Ben knows more
about what actually got through
um but a lot of the things that you're
bringing up like uh streamline approval
process transparency of fees training
not mandatory but training like some of
that stuff got through some of it didn't
can you tell me if there's been any I
mean it's very new but if there's any
effect on the way towns respond yeah I
would say it's it's still too new I
think it's going to take a little time
for um uh for for towns to um
I guess move forward and it may take a
lot longer for some other towns to move
forward
um but I I don't know and I don't always
think that it's the uh on the on the
planning side so in some instances we've
moved we've we've we've moved um
relatively quite expeditiously through
the planning process and
um I may sound like a broken record
because I've said this at many many
there's always a disconnect between the
fire jurisdiction and the and the uh and
the building and planning jurisdiction I
I would say that that's kind of a
um synonymous across communities and so
we may make it through the planning
process and we make it make it through
the planning division but fire moves at
their own pace and
um we'll come back with changes that
mean might mean you need to start over
or you might need to add significant
things to your project that are going to
cost a lot more and so I don't know how
that I don't know how to break that I
don't know how to change that I know in
some jurisdictions they've moved
building Under Fire as opposed to under
planning but um but I'm not sure how to
how to rectify that but but it's
definitely an issue and something on my
agenda is to is to bring in code
enforcers because I want to know like
once once an approval is made by the
planning board
then like code gets say of it and it
kind of just like
there there's there's another set of
roadblocks right there with code and
then does it have to go back to planning
in some regards sometimes it might yep
so I do want to bring in and see if
there's anything on the code side that
we can look at too that might be
hindering the process making it slower
for that and I do know that housing
action I think it was housing action
that was responsible for training a few
years ago to bring code enforcement and
fire officials into sort of the same
room around education and cooperation in
that in that Avenue
um so anything like that I think would
be helpful okay any questions
representative
thank you
um it seemed like uh
uh you were implying that maybe the we
should also talk to fire in addition to
code people and how what um they're
seeing as far as maybe plans that get
approved that are not you know let's say
ready for prime time
um and so have to go back to the drawing
board costing everyone time and money
um
is an
um another
I mean one do you agree with that and
then two do
um also
seem to be
implying that maybe they're
is an opportunity for the state to S to
say
um you know
that you have some you know your local
municipality has some guidelines and
if you
if you feel that those are inadequate
that you need to change your regulation
before imposing them on new projects or
something along those lines as far as to
to make sure that you know going in
that you're meeting what you need to
meet instead of having surprise like
doubling the work right you already did
them you already designed this now you
have to go and redesign it because
additional things and I I don't mean to
disparage fire departments that's not
what I came to do
um but but I'm I'm more than implying uh
I'll tell you straight up this this is
this is a real issue and I'm not the
only developer that will that will
attest to this but um
the code and the regulations need to be
clear and upfront and we're going to
design and build to that it's the
frustrating part that we encounter is
that there's all there are all these
Unwritten rules in nearly every
jurisdiction whether it may it may be
the code and building side but
oftentimes it's it's more on the fire
side predominantly I think because Fire
doesn't have the time to invest on the
front end of your project that we need
we need that feedback in response early
on as opposed to at the end of the day
I'll give you I'll give you a good
example of
um of how this can happen I got a
development approval from the planning
board
um the the road ordinance for the town
said if your road is more than 900 feet
long you have to have a second means of
egress
and so our road was 600 feet long our
engineer designed a project with a 600
Foot Road to to provide the number of
units that we were going to build and
after we made it through the planning
process the we hadn't gotten through our
approval but in the design review of the
planning process when all the agencies
in this in the town come together the
fire said we want a second means of
egress and so
the ordinance said it's only required on
900 foot roads not 600 foot roads in the
fire chief that it doesn't matter second
means of egress so when we went for
approval the night of our approval the
planning board chair
sitting in his chair in front of his
microphone said on the record there's
nothing in the ordinance that requires
me to make you put in a second means of
egress for a 600 foot road but because
the fire chief wants it we're going to
make that a condition of your approval
so my project cost just went up by half
a million dollars because now I had to
build a second means of egress that was
infeasible and unpractical the planning
department did not want a second means
of egress because of traffic issues so
we ended up constructing a gated road
that only the fire department has access
to that I have to maintain in perpetuity
so
it again I don't mean to disparage the
fire because it's about Public Safety
but it's about having rules and
regulations and ordinances in place that
we could that can be adhered to and and
not changed and made up later on down
the road so well that's our job is to
find out this kind of
thank you I have a simple solution we
the legislature at the state and the
federal level shall not make any
retrospective laws it's not
constitutional as such I think the
planning boards and code they have to
stick by those ordinances and
regulations in place at the time of
issuance of said permits and stick to it
full stop I too I'm a small time
developer and I had run into that hurdle
that sometimes turns into a mountain
multiple times
played nice up until now
so I I oh I'm sorry can I yeah I I
totally agree with that and um
you know I walk away from the meeting
and I'm thinking thinking and you know I
want to challenge it I want to fight it
I want to but we're a non-profit
affordable housing developer and so at
the end of the day our mission is to get
the project built and provide affordable
housing and so for us to go through an
appeals process to go through a a a
rather difficult mudslinging event with
the town you've got to ask yourself at
the end of the day is it worth it to get
to the end result which is why I was a
proponent of the housing appeals board
so that I think that remedies will be
handed down as a result of that like I
said I hope it's never me that has to go
into that seat but I'm glad it's there
for that reason so
representative Walsh yeah thank you Mr
chair and um thank you for coming in uh
he may have just touched on one of the
biggest things this committee can
probably solve because I see it in my
town too uh as a matter of fact I have a
bill in public works right now that are
addressing a last minute change by the
fire department uh it happens all the
time I won't belabor it now
um but we might want to look at the ahj
authority in our fire codes and I would
certainly include the fire department in
our discussions in the future but a
quick question for you while um
you did make mention that even if you
had the density you had the water you
had the sewage and free land
it still wouldn't be feasible with the
construction costs have you repriced
anything since they have kind of
plateaued and come down I know it might
be too late for some of these projects
but yeah I guess my question is are you
seeing anything good on the horizon with
with the way the prices for Building
Products it was and then interest rates
went up like seven percent so
um so uh yeah I think I mean we you know
I was very fortunate that we did not
have a new construction project being
priced during the pandemic we were
wrapping up our our big project in
Merrimack in 2020 and so we had locked
in prices we only experienced one month
delay because of because of building
material supply issues and it came in uh
relatively on time and on budget we've
been doing 101 unit rehab over the last
two years that's been very very
challenging uh you know it took us
almost a year to get kitchen cabinets we
had to order our furnaces a year in
advance things with electrical
components and Metal Products are still
really expensive and very short supply a
big challenge right now is with utility
services providers like evernorth and
trying to get your Transformers in place
so that you can actually deliver a power
to your new building you might have a
brand spanking new building with no
electricity in it and so um so some
things have definitely normalized um or
not normalized but price is coming down
for drywall and two by fours and plywood
that that really peaked during the
during the covet pandemic but um now
with interest rates where they are I
think that that's really gonna
have an impact on everything else so so
going back to having a 250 000 per unit
TDC I don't see returning to that
anytime soon and so when I say it's not
feasible or not practical for us to
develop an affordable unit at the end of
the day in order to come in under the
state's definition of Workforce housing
which is 60 of the area median income my
rent has to be it can be no more than
this and so in order for me to pay for
these additional other costs where does
the money come from now I have to
increase the amount that I have to
borrow
so my debt service goes up the amount of
interest I'm paying goes up now I can't
make the utility payments the taxes the
insurance all of the expenses operating
costs Meet The Debt Service and stay
under that rent without some other form
of subsidy we don't rely heavily on
operating subsidies uh you know we just
expect our tenants to pay the rent and
so in order to be able to deliver that
rent uh at an affordable price something
has to give on the on the development
side and so it would take a built-in
subsidy on the front end over and above
what we can get from New Hampshire
housing's normal programs
yeah yeah thank you Mr chair
um
you you deal with a lot of different
municipalities and this is going towards
finding out after the fact
planning boards approved that now you
have these expensive changes how many of
these towns did you deal with have a
technical Review Committee
most of the towns we work with there's a
good opportunity to do tech review on
the front end and honestly some
sometimes it does come up at that point
where someone will say I know the
ordinance says we only have to have a 35
foot wide road but we want a 50-foot
wide Road at technical review so I guess
that's helpful because at least I know
before I've invested a couple hundred
thousand dollars in engineering but
still it's it's not written in the
origins so but yeah tech reviews is I
would say tech review is pretty common
okay in most of the communities we work
with
yeah it's better that they tell you up
front instead of shooting you down and
then having you come back correct yeah
and what's even harder is when you've
got a completed building
and your enunciators or your sprinklers
are
not in the right place or inadequate or
something and it's like it was designed
it was reviewed it was designed to code
it was reviewed and then it was inspect
and then upon inspection at the end
you're telling me it's wrong and now
I've got to go back and move this stuff
and so it can be it can be expensive so
very expensive any last uh questions
before we
go out to Ben
good afternoon Mr chairman committee
members my name is Ben Frost I'm the
deputy executive director and chief
legal officer at New Hampshire housing
um
I have a this PowerPoint presentation
that I can walk through and it has two
basic parts to it one is an introduction
to you who New Hampshire housing is uh
and the programs that we administer and
I've heard a series of questions coming
up both this morning I was watching the
live stream which is a great service to
the public thank you
um and there are different questions
that came up in this afternoon too as
well about the different programs that
we administer but then also the second
part is look at the market and I know
you you got some of that this morning
from uh Bob Quinn and Chris Norwood from
the New Hampshire Association of
Realtors and I have some uh different
angles on that but also look at the
rental market which I don't think they
um and I I'll you know happy to take any
questions along the way I also recognize
time is limited and I really want to
hear what it is plenty of time
um I I told he's right out there I told
him we're a little behind so okay thanks
take your time
uh New Hampshire housing is uh one of
many state Housing Finance agencies each
state has something similar to us
although we're all different in one way
or another uh New Hampshire housing was
created by the legislature in 1981 and
you heard this morning Steve Lewis
talking about the New Hampshire Housing
Commission that was formed in the mid
70s along with the New Hampshire housing
agency and those two were combined in
1981 by the legislature to create the
New Hampshire Housing Finance Authority
and we have been in existence in that
form since 1981.
uh we are
um a component unit of state government
we're not part of the executive branch
we're not a state agency we're not a
department of state government but a
corporation formed by the legislature to
provide financing and administer housing
programs for the people of New Hampshire
we don't receive and never have receive
any operating funding from the state we
do administer as I think Robert alluded
to Robert Turney alluded to the state's
affordable housing trust fund so that is
funded by the legislature we administer
that on behalf of the state but we don't
take admin out of that it goes all goes
to development 100 you see on the first
page here our board of directors top
left is Chris Norwood who appeared
before you this morning he's the chair
of our board a couple of our members by
Statute represent specific industry
sectors so Chris represents real estate
Trisha Warren represents a single-family
building and Evelyn Welton represents
banking so those are by Statute
positions that get filled on our board
you see also Mike Skelton is on our
board of directors the executive
director and CEO of the business and
industry Association
our members our board members are
nominated by the governor and appointed
by the executive Council moving on we
have three principal uh lines of
business if you will uh one is
homeownership and so we uh we do not
deal directly with home buyers we work
with a a group of Mortgage Bankers
mortgage Originators and local and
Regional Banks which originate the loans
sometimes in their name sometimes in our
name uh and so we're they're the ones
who are the the boots on the ground if
you will of uh doing the mortgage work
we then acquire those mortgages uh from
the the mortgage Originators or we close
them in our own name and then we sell
them into the secondary market so we're
in a kind of an aggregator of mortgages
but we offer a wide range of mortgage
programs that are really targeted to
principally the first time home buyer
not exclusively but principally the
first time home buyer
um and our job by Statute is to find
those places where the private Market
doesn't really work that well and the
first time home buyer is a really good
example of that so the banks uh who who
would do this work uh if they had the
the capital and risk profile for it uh
use us instead to absorb that
um and it's worked really well over the
past 40 years
so you see our mortgage programs how
much we we have done in the in the past
fiscal year and some of the um some of
the data associated with that
um
we also
and there's actually
yeah I skipped over I flipped to page
page the next page multi-family Housing
Finance uh so uh Robert turini uh and
the folks from Elm Grove talked about
the low income housing tax credit that
is a U.S treasury program not HUD but
treasury program that we administer on
behalf of the treasury so we are the uh
the um the allocator of the federal
low-income housing tax credit for New
Hampshire and that is
here in New Hampshire and Across the
Nation it is the principal source of
development capital for low-income
housing rental construction Ben do you
Mr Frosty do the um inspections for that
too we do so we we have an asset
management division we have a in our
multi-family housing division we have uh
an asset management group and a
Development Group the Development Group
originates these projects um and works
with the developers to make them work uh
and you know to find the gaps in
financing and we also as as Robert I'm
sure we'll attest we have some really
rigorous designing construction
standards so we compel developers to
build to a very high quality because
this is an asset that we want to last
for a long time because our asset
management group is looking at this
stuff over time uh doing the the annual
inspections doing the unit inspections
inspecting the books on each and every
development to make sure that they're
financially solvent
um we have and we uh administer if we
have in our portfolio something like 400
projects uh totaling uh roughly 5 000
housing units across the state
uh we have not foreclosed on a
multi-family project since the mid-1980s
and those we foreclose on two one was in
Franklin it was a project that we
assumed from the Franklin housing
authority and it was just not in good
shape the other one was a a project in
Peterborough that
um I think was ill-advised from the the
get-go but not since the 1980s have we
foreclosed on any multi-family housing
developments that we Finance which I
think is a testament to the the rigor
with which we underwrite the projects uh
they they if they're not sound they're
not going to go forward
and here's an example this is a slide
four on the second page of some of the
the projects that we financed
um
we talked about the home ownership
programs the last business line division
that we have is the assisted housing
division and there's been some
discussion with earlier speakers about
the housing Choice voucher program we
are a public housing agency under
federal law uh but we we don't own and
operate public housing we are a what's
known as a voucher only public housing
agency
so there are a series of local public
housing agencies in New Hampshire that
also administer some allocation of
housing Choice vouchers we do
effectively Statewide the balance of the
state and we administer as you see over
4 000 housing Choice vouchers there's
roughly 10 000 vouchers administered
Statewide by all of the public housing
agencies total
we administer that 4200 plus it's
actually more like 4 500 because there's
a variety of different vouchers I think
depending upon the funding source and
there's also the the emergency vouchers
that were funded through
um through arpa not shown here but it's
come up in in some in some of the
earlier uh speakers discussions with you
we we also administer a couple of the
pandemic related Housing Programs so the
emergency rental assistance program
we're doing that under contract with
gopher
and that is winding down it will be
fully closed out by June of this year uh
all told this will have provided rental
resources to New Hampshire residents in
need of those resources something on the
order of 250 million dollars all federal
money
um the other program also mentioned by
earlier speakers is the homeowner
assistance fund uh and it's pretty
self-explanatory it's to provide
assistance to homeowners who are
experiencing difficulties uh as a result
of or during covet uh paying their their
mortgage paying their utilities paying
their property taxes or other property
related costs like
homeowner association fees and condo
fees and things like that
um
that will continue to run for a couple
of years uh and the the funding uh if
that's a total of 50 million dollars and
that that is moving relatively slowly I
think in part because of the uh the
controls that we put on the program so
we're requiring uh if someone is seeking
Mortgage Assistance we're requiring them
to go through lost mitigation with their
mortgage servicer first to see if
there's an opportunity there to change
the terms of the mortgage to meet their
needs before they come to this program
for assistance and if they have done
that and still have problems then
um
I made a note to myself to cover
something that came up when the folks
from Elm Grove were talking with you and
that's with regard to the housing Choice
Voucher Program uh
um I think it was a Chris schleyer who
mentioned moving to work and that is a
it's a
relatively new HUD program something
that Congress designed and HUD is is
implementing
um and we were just in the past year
designated as a moving to work agency so
it's a competitive we applied for it and
were awarded this what that does is it
gives us substantial flexibility in how
to administer the housing Choice voucher
program so for example in the frequency
of inspections and it's not every month
or even every other month it's you know
the the annual inspections we can using
a moving to work designation under
appropriate circumstances we can move
that to biennial inspections so if the
property is in good shape it doesn't
need to be inspected every year unless
we get a complaint
and if there's and we'll go out and
respond to any complaint of a tenant and
if we find a violation then we will act
on it
so that's one example of the flexibility
that moving to work designation will
give to us
the last
uh area that we are active in and it's
not a business line division but it's a
a group this is the group that I
supervise at New Hampshire housing it's
our policy planning and Communications
Group we do the research planning and
advocacy uh and you see listed here a
lot of different things uh so for
example we are running the invest NH
Municipal Planning and Zoning grant
program on behalf of the Department of
Business and economic Affairs that's a
five million dollar grant program for
municipalities to change their zoning to
make them
more housing friendly
the point being to create a regulatory
environment at the local level that is
more conducive to Housing Development
and I will tell you we launched this on
August 5th
and we have already made over 40 grants
to municipalities
totaling over 2.1 million dollars the
demand for this program is exceedingly
High meaning that the municipalities are
cities and towns and get it
they understand that there's a problem
with housing Supply in New Hampshire and
they want to be part of the solution not
all of them but the ones that certainly
the ones that we've made granted well
let me ask you this then um
have those towns you've awarded the
grants to have they historically been
towns that have been
I'm not saying good or bad on housing
but like towns have been more open to
more development or have they been
closed towns it runs the gamut Mr
chairman so there are some communities
that have been
historically less welcoming to Housing
Development who are trying to change
and an important element of all of these
grants is
a requirement that they do community
engagement that is is really
um boots on the ground work with the
public to get people to understand get
the voters to understand what the issues
are and why it's important to do these
things you're not going to convince
everyone
but if you can convince a significant
majority of people who are going to show
up at the polls on town meeting day then
yes you're a much better position to
um and then there are others that have
just been doing the right thing for a
while and they want to do more of it
which is great
um we also do a great variety of studies
and reports and I'll touch on those a
little bit later
um and conferences and I think you've
all received an invitation to our home
ownership conference on March 8th in
Bedford at the Manchester Country Club
it's all morning it's a great program I
know you it might be a session day and I
apologize so I actually wanted to make
this an off-site meeting of the special
committee but unfortunately there's
other committees that are meeting that
day here in Concord I don't think it's
going to be a session day but if there's
some things that maybe you could bring
like presentations to us on another day
I'm certainly willing to entertain that
be happy to do that we're not recording
the conference but I can tell you
um two of the speakers that we have John
and Maggie Randolph now you might have
seen on wmmur recently they are the ones
doing the I won't call them tiny houses
but they are tiny houses small homes in
Dover for their employees they're the
owners of Harmony Homes which is
long-term long-term care facilities in
Durham and I think also Dover and maybe
elsewhere too and they were finding they
just they couldn't hire people because
the people couldn't afford to move here
because they couldn't afford they
couldn't find a place to live so they
said well why don't we build something
and working cooperatively with the city
of Dover they were able to build in this
is under construction now and I think
nearing ready for occupancy I think 43
um single units that are for rent for
their employees principally but also for
others and these are roughly 450 square
feet plus Loft area they they're going
to be speaking at our conference I
encourage you to invite them to speak to
the committee I was looking at the
agenda and the presentations I don't
know if any we all received the email
there's some great presentations on that
list so if there's anybody interested we
can invite them to testify
right I'd be happy to do that now
quickly just taking a look at the market
I don't want to repeat what the folks
from the Realtors uh Association have
said but focusing on the the rental
market uh annually New Hampshire housing
does a residential rental cost survey it
is a an extraordinarily robust survey we
survey something on the order of 20 000
units uh Statewide in collaboration with
the UNH Survey Center and other
contractors uh who go out and and get uh
landlords to respond to this we get
really good data on what the rental
market is in New Hampshire the best data
available and the data show this is a
slide 11
that the rental costs are going up and
up and up if you extend this back in
time to like 1995 you would see it's
been going up since that time
um it was really only in the early 90s
that we saw real stability in the rental
market and that was because we had such
a surplus of of housing that had been
built in the 80s and then we had the
crash of the late 80s early 90s
so but since 1995 rental costs have been
going up and there's kind of an
acceleration here in this curve
things are not getting better we're in
the uh the the process right now of
updating that survey and we will have
the results published most likely in
July
um and you see also the the vacancy
rates
um uh
on the next page
and I think Don referred to this uh in
her testimony
um Statewide all units total 0.5 percent
um and for two bedroom units which is
the bulk of the supply is 0.3 percent
and representative of your pillow has a
question I think oh representative
thank you I just wanted to
um clarify when you're saying rental
cost
are you talking about the
um cost
of providing the rental or the cost to
the end user the the actual rent of the
apartment that is contract rent so that
is what the tenant pays okay beautiful
yes thank you and we account for very
sometimes the tenants pay the utilities
sometimes they don't so we account for
that so what we what the result is is
the gross rent so rent plus utilities is
what we're representing here
uh and you see the vacancy rates uh by
County things are tough all over doesn't
matter where you are in the state
there's not enough rental housing
uh
the last thing I have on the ranch is
really a transition to ownership of the
household income by tenure that is
ownership versus renters uh and you see
how static uh the income has been over
time of uh their renter households uh
they've just not gone up now no one's
income has gone up to keep up with
housing costs whether you're on owner or
a renter but it's been especially hard
for renters what I don't show here is
eviction data and and that is available
by the uh from the judicial branch
they've been reporting on this uh really
well that they've just converted how
they report that from weekly to monthly
so we're kind of sorting through what
that looks like I can tell you that the
eviction data what they have presented
up to now shows that
the level of evictions are down somewhat
from where they were pre-covered
which is a good sign but there's still a
significant significant number of
evictions going on Statewide and that's
really where New Hampshire legal
assistance is plays such an important
role
moving to the purchase site this is kind
of repetitious of what the real through
said so I won't dwell on this other than
to look at this is Slide 19.
um the prices
uh and I show you know December 20 to
December 22 a 22 increase if we go back
pre-covet December 2019.
we've seen through December 22 2022 a 48
increase in sales prices
um this is the median sales price uh so
there's a an extraordinary acceleration
I think it was um it may have been Chris
Norway this morning we talked about uh
the the velocity increasing that's
acceleration and you can see kind of the
inflection point in this curve around
2020 uh where it really took off and
this is what we've been hearing about in
the news for the past couple years
uh dampened somewhat but not a whole lot
by the increase increase in interest
rates you know they bottomed out in 20
December of 2020 at I think 2.79 which
was the lowest this is the Freddie Mac
survey of of national mortgage interest
rates and that was the lowest they had
ever recorded in the 40-year history
actually 50-year history of that survey
now it's you know six point something
percent which seems high
but if you compare it to where it was
in the early 80s no it's not so bad they
have stabilized and that's I think a
good thing but they're up and the
interest rates are having an impact on
people's ability to afford a home so we
see a sales down
and it's especially difficult for the
the buyers that we serve the first time
um
also questions came up where where are
people coming from and you know Chris
Norwich sitting in this chair said I see
all the Massachusetts license plates and
anybody confessed
um you know maybe that's that's what I'm
looking for you know if you if you if
you look if you think something's
happening then you're going to see it
happening in fact
we have not seen a huge increase in
buyers from out of state
most of our buyers come from New
Hampshire and in fact most of the buyers
in New Hampshire come from the town or
the proximate region in which they
already live whether they already own a
home or they're renting most buyers are
local to their own markets we have seen
a small increase small but I would say
statistically significant increase in
buyers from out of state and this is
part of it's from Massachusetts yeah and
it's the the people decamping the Boston
metro area during covid uh and but I
think most of those were are coming here
and occupying homes that they already
owned
and now many of them are going back
um
it'll be interesting to see what happens
to the home buyer profile over time as
other places other parts of the country
become
um less great to live in like I'm
thinking about the mega drought in the
southwest and fires in the Pacific
Northwest
these are these are things that people
are going to be dealing with in the
future
and New Hampshire
all of New England is going to be a
really great place to live and better in
perspective in perspective uh to those
changes elsewhere so we might see more
of that happening
um delinquencies
they're down but they're going up you
know the forbearance covered related
forbearance is ending uh and so we're
expecting that to be more of an issue
going forward
number of people talked about what's the
problem the problem is Supply we're
simply not building enough housing and
if you look at the slide 25 this goes
this is building permit data
um elected by the office of Planning and
Development
um and you see uh where we are
the lowest points on this curve are
periods of recession 1980 81 82 1991.
we are building at recessionary levels
right now and we've been building at
recessionary levels during
the period of the nation's longest
economic expansion in our history
this is economically unsustainable for
us as a state
we need to be building more
Chris Norwood said he'd like to see us
build build uh four or five thousand
units a year
I think he's off
by a hundred percent I think we need to
be building more like nine or ten
thousand units a year to meet the demand
that we see going forward and to account
for the shortage we have right now
how much housing does New Hampshire need
great question right now we've got a
shortage of something like 23 000 units
to get us to a stable Market on the
renter side and on the owner's side
and this this accounts for this this
last slide here counts for
um growth in the future population
changes household composition changes
people moving to the state
uh which we need
um you know look look at the well we
don't have one ads anymore but go on
indeed and any any uh hiring Pro uh
platform and you'll see so many openings
talk to any employer talk to the Bia
they'll tell you we need workers workers
need houses
so I end with
this offer this question what can we do
to help you
um we have a really robust research
group we have the best source of of
housing data in the state if you have
questions we will attempt to answer them
just ask we do the the data analysis we
do the residential rental cost survey we
have data from the Warren group on home
purchases which takes the pa34 US from
dra and filters them we we look at every
D recording in the state
and we also do independent research
right now we're we're looking at the
school costs of new residential
construction this is stuff that Russ
Tebow had done for us years ago Russ has
retired and we have a new firm working
with us to look at this you know so and
you talked to Robert Turney talked to
the folks from Elm Grove and they tell
you that there's a lot of resistance
locally part of that resistance is all
the kids that'll come with this low
income housing well let's take a look at
the numbers the numbers don't say that
there's actually very few kids that come
with any kind of development whether
it's single-family homes or multi-family
low-income rental construction typically
it's related to the number of bedrooms
in a house bigger homes tend to have
more kids
it's pretty simple math we will also be
looking at the cost the property value
impact
on surrounding properties when you build
new low-income rental housing this is
you know it's gonna it's gonna kill my
property values
not what we've seen elsewhere it
actually raises property values but we
need to demonstrate that from a New
Hampshire perspective we know that we're
also looking at the impact of short-term
rentals on the housing market we don't
know what the story is yet we're just
looking at the data
and finally the um our policy and
Communications we do a lot of work with
Grassroots organizations helping them to
communicate locally but we also
um I will I will contradict what my
friend Steve Lewis said this morning
about New Hampshire housing being
hamstrung uh and and being worried about
the funding well I said we don't get
operational funding from the state and
we have been I would say active and
aggressive with the legislature so 2008
we worked with the New Hampshire legal
assistants to write the workforce
housing law 2016 we worked with the home
builders to write the accessory dwelling
unit law 2019 we wrote the housing
appeals board legislation for Senator
Bob Guida and this year we wrote the
governor's request the legislation
introduced by Senator Dan Ennis the
historic housing tax credit which we'll
have a hearing next Tuesday
in Senate committee so we're we're ready
to speak up but we're also ready to help
answer your questions thank you Mr Frost
are there questions for Ben Frost
representative
thank you
um you were talking about the
um research that you're doing as far as
um children per unit or per bedroom
um I'm interested if you are if you plan
on breaking that data down by like
um you know let's say children per unit
that or per per uh per unit that has one
bedroom per unit that has two bedroom
per unit that like if you have a three
bedroom house if you build a bunch of
three bedroom houses you're gonna
probably get more children than if you
build a bunch of one bedroom unit houses
um if you will be showing that in in
your data when you um are you breaking
it down by that yes representative that
is the plan beautiful
oh yeah yes
um
there is a discussion I guess earlier
about the inspections and how often
they're happening and by all the
different agencies
um that might because maybe your your
agency may be only inspecting let's say
every year or maybe even now every two
years but there may be other agencies
um or funding sources or whatever that
are inspecting also
um and there was some hint of a
discussion about is there a way or is it
is it feasible to possibly have let's
say your organization be uh your
inspection to also qualify for those
other inspections and and and therefore
reducing the number of inspections in
general
um maybe they would be accepted or maybe
we could offer like you know hey if
you're if you're interested we could
save you money by by doing the
inspection and letting you know what we
think kind of a thing um if
what are your thoughts on that this is a
great
and it there's the I'll answer on a
couple of different levels
um one is there
different types of inspections so
there's the construction inspection so
while something is under construction
and we we have
created a model agreement that we are
using now with different funders so that
um you know so that the banks don't need
to send their inspector uh and other
entities don't need to send their
inspector we hire the inspector and they
agree to accept the results of our
inspection so that limits the
inspections during construction but the
the subject that was at discussion this
morning was it you know it's already
occupied and and you get the
um you know the the the Section 8
housing Choice voucher inspection from
looking at the quality of the the unit
you get maybe an inspector looking at
based on funding from the tax credit
um so that does occur I would say in a
in an ideal world yes
it and it's an outstanding idea the
difficulty of course is that we're
dealing with multiple funding sources
that have
um
regulations that we must follow so
mostly these this is a federal question
and I don't want to I don't want to say
oh it's the fact that we can do nothing
about it uh because I think we can do
something about it that's not something
that the legislature here really is in a
position to do this is a federal
question because most of these sources
are federal in nature uh we do try to
minimize the inspection burden on the
property owner the landlord and on the
tenant and yes I recognize the
imposition that it poses on a tenant
sometimes though it's a it's a response
to a tenant complaint so they're asking
us to come
um and and that we will do that at any
time
representative Phillips I've remembered
my actual actual second question
um
that other one was on the Fly
um because I forgot the the second one
um there was a discussion earlier about
how
um kind of the agency
was previously
offering Services I guess as far as
um
training or advising local
municipalities or or or developers that
see some problems going on at local
municipalities about their application
of Law and how their sense was that the
that the agency wasn't doing that as
much anymore do you believe that that is
the case that you are reduced that
amount or that you never really did it
or that
um that maybe that would be a good
service that that would incentivize
municipalities to
kind of follow their the the spirit and
the and the regulations that are in
place right now and maybe there isn't
any additional regulations necessary
it's just enforcement of the current
ones representative I do recall the
question the the comment from Steve
Lewis who was uh talking about the
um the former New Hampshire Housing
Commission which existed in the 1970s
which is when he got his start as a home
builder in Atkinson
um and and I think that there was a
certain level of activism at that time
by the commission I will say we at New
Hampshire housing we have from time to
time engaged in as interveners and
litigations so in the um that the really
important Britain versus Chester case it
was decision of the New Hampshire
Supreme Court in 1991 the litigation
began in 1986 we were interveners in
that case on behalf of the builders and
the would-be tenants
and also we assisted with the litigation
that great bridge properties took
against the town of ossipy and I think
you remember this
um and so we we one of our employees was
an expert witness in that case so and so
we we do have some capacity to do that
but really what what you're talking
about is is not the litigation but
before you get to that point uh helping
with the municipal boards uh it's not
something we've done I don't know that
it's something that we've considered but
it's something I I think is not a bad
idea and I'll certainly take it back
thank you any other representative Walsh
yep thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question
um and I hope you didn't and I apologize
for leaving the room for a minute I had
to step out I hope you didn't answer my
question while I was gone
um
I've asked this uh it's just for more
data I've asked the question a couple
different ways probably not that well uh
has there been you've obviously compiled
a bunch of data here most of it's by
county and I am looking and seeing that
the problem is not as severe in every
County as it is in others so my question
is because I know in Hooksett we are
currently the planning board adopted or
uh
hired out we're doing our own housing
needs assessment
to assess what you need you have to know
what you have
so has it gone down to the town level in
any of your studies on what is currently
there for a mix of housing town by town
because I don't think every town needs
the same solution as the others per se I
agree this is a great question
representative the
um what I'll say is that we have not
done that however and you might be aware
of this the state's nine Regional
planning commissions working with the
office of Planning and Development I
have for the past year and a half two
years been working on Regional Housing
needs assessments which are looking at
not just the regional need but figuring
out what each individual municipalities
responsibility is in meeting that need
and so there's What's this called a fair
share analysis and allocation so each
municipality should be able to look to
the Regional Housing needs assessment
and see okay this is what we've got to
do now the an individual municipality
might do its own analysis as Hooksett is
doing and come up with a different
number probably because the depth of
your analysis will be that much greater
than what the regional Planning
Commission is doing because no one knows
your town as well as you do and you have
the capacity to look
more closely at what's going on than the
regional Planning Commission would or us
or the office of Planning and
so at this point it's pretty much
voluntarily town to town there is
nothing that's been done or
well there's no no compelling
way to get this information well the the
Regional Housing needs assessments are
nearing completion so those those will
be available very soon for all of the
throughout the state each Regional
Planning Commission is doing its own
analysis and have may have its own
different timeline
um
they are required to do this the
regional planning commissions are
required by law to do a Regional Housing
needs assessment every five years that's
part of their statutory mandate uh and
uh so they they do that what's not
required is that fair share analysis and
allocation that's not in statute but is
based on
um in the Britain versus Chester lawsuit
from the 90s and also on the workforce
housing law which says that every
municipality must provide its fair share
of the Region's current and reasonably
foreseeable future need for Workforce
housing
thank you for that and I believe they
are a month or so away you're right okay
great thank you
perfect so any other questions thank you
Mr Boss appreciate it I'm sure you'll be
back I'd be happy to come back we are
nearing the end of work on our state
white housing needs assessment and I'd
love to come back and present the
results that would be great 200 Page
study which I can condense
yes
um so with that I'm gonna take maybe a
five minute break and let our next
witness
um set up
um his computer and things so with that
we'll we'll get back together around 2
okay so we are back House special
committee on housing
um so I would like to invite or or
um introduce my friend Jason sorens I
initially met him a few years ago at St
ansem College event he was uh at the
time working for St Andrew College
college of Ethics business and
governance
um which is a great organization aims at
getting people
um like moral like building a better
moral foundation for the state through
Ethics in governance
um so since then he's moved on so he's
now senior research Factory at American
Institute for economic research but
um Jason's been doing quite a bit of
research on New Hampshire zoning so as
soon as we thought zoning we brought it
up in the first meeting I instantly knew
that
um you would have something to
contribute so you'd recently came out
with some research and um so I would
like you to at least present and let us
let us learn more great thank you Mr
chair and thank you Representatives
um I was told to allocate an hour but my
presentation is only about 30 minutes so
there should be plenty of time for
questions
um so I am talking about New Hampshire
zoning laws and uh their effect
especially on the housing market today
so a little bit about the nature of
zoning in New Hampshire
um RSA 674 is really the core
legislative grant of authority the
so-called zoning enabling act for
municipalities
um and uh and neighboring chapters sort
of Flesh that out
so when you think about zoning there's
really zoning strictly defined which has
to do with separating uses and and
limiting density but then you also have
other land use planning powers that
municipalities have subdivision
regulations site plan regulations and
building codes and those are all based
in this chapter of statutes
um over time
the the state's regulation and and
grants of power to municipalities have
become more complex and detailed uh so
for instance Innovative land use
controls is a long list of
um so-called Innovative zoning
authorities that uh municipalities can
off uh Implement and authorize and the
state has given them the power to do
that historic Heritage Agriculture and
housing commissions are all things have
been added over time
uh if you look at the statutes there are
a few ways in which the state explicitly
constrains what United municipalities
can do with zoning especially related to
housing so for instance inclusionary
zoning is authorized as an as an
Innovative land use control inclusionary
zoning
is a a tool that provides an incentive
to a builder developer to maintain
guaranteed affordability for some of the
units and it usually has some sort of
income test so some of the units have to
be rented or sold at below Market rates
to
renters or buyers who have incomes below
a certain level
however the state requires this only be
implemented as a voluntary incentive
some other states like California have
mandatory inclusionary zoning where a
town can simply say if you want to build
anything it has to include these
price-controlled units
a second way that the state preempts
local zoning manufactured housing has to
be allowed in most of the land area
zoned for residential according to the
language of the statute so that is a way
in which New Hampshire constrains uh
local zoning Authority probably more
strongly than other New England states
the workforce housing law that that Ben
Frost mentioned for instance I'm sure
other speakers today have mentioned that
every municipality must allow reasonable
and realistic opportunities for the
development of Workforce housing on a
majority of residentially zoned land
that doesn't mean multi-family housing
has to be allowed on a majority of
residentially zoned land but there has
to be the capability reasonable and
realistic opportunities to develop some
kind of Workforce housing whether it's
single-family owner occupied Workforce
housing or multi-family there is a
common misconception that Workforce
housing is this inclusionary housing
that's not necessarily the case
according to statute it simply has to be
affordable and that's defined in statute
but that could be naturally affordable
it could be sold at a market rate that
is nevertheless affordable
and and count as Workforce housing
accessory dwelling units or accessory
apartments or in-law apartments
um must be allowed by municipalities and
places where detached single-family
homes are allowed but municipalities May
Place certain restrictions on them
nationally there are other states that
have that have also implemented a law
like this California recently
but New Hampshire's is one of the the
furthest reaching in terms of
restricting ways in which municipalities
so what are the characteristics of local
ordinances in New Hampshire are there
any ways we can sort of generalize well
the usual purposes of zoning regulations
not just in New Hampshire but throughout
the United States are first of all
separating uses and limiting density and
so zoning zoning ordinances are paired
with zoning Maps the zoning map will
show different districts and those
districts are intended for different
uses so commercial use is allowed over
here residential uses a lot over there
industrial uses over there
and in some cases you could allow
multiple uses in a district and and some
municipalities do that but this is sort
of the classic rationale for zoning is
to separate uses that are thought to be
incompatible but the second purpose of
zoning is is a very very common one and
pretty pretty much ubiquitous and that
is to limit density to either require
minimum lot size sizes or just a direct
maximum number of units allowed in a
particular unit of land like an acre
that is a very common feature of zoning
ordinances in our state and in other
states as well
19 municipalities a little under 10 lack
zoning all of these are rural uh they're
they're up north
um for the most part I think lemster is
the furthest uh South one in some of
them subdivision regulations still
function to limit density so some of
them actually set minimum lot sizes in
their subdivision regulations so they're
effectively still doing a zoning type
function and then there are 14 other
municipalities that technically have
zoning but the entire town is a single
District so they're not really doing the
separation of uses function and so it's
not very clear how a town that
supposedly lacks zoning but nevertheless
restricts density in some other way is
it really any different from a town that
restricts density town wide but doesn't
um typical features of New Hampshire
zoning ways in which New Hampshire
zoning is a little bit different maybe
from the rest of the U.S or at least
certain parts of the rest of the US most
residential land area is reserved for
single family only detached single
family
um now that is that is quite common in
other places as well but um it's
probably stronger here because we're a
more rural State than a lot of other
states
um we frequently see in New Hampshire
that small scale commercial operations
let's say Corner groceries and things
like that are allowed in in residential
districts not certainly not always
um but in about half of the residential
land area you'll see at least some
general category of commercial use
allowed which is and it's often rural
areas which is a little bit different
from some other places and my hypothesis
for this is that towns want the tax
revenue that commercial development
brings and so there's a direct incentive
for them to allow commercial development
um a feature of of New England zoning uh
that just everyone in this field knows
about it's the land of high minimum lot
sizes so minimum minimum lot size is
constraining
um a house to be built on a large piece
of land and that's very typical in New
Hampshire and in other New England
states but is rarer in in the rest of
the country
in New Hampshire one of the interesting
things I think is maybe even a little
bit different from some of the other New
England states is that uh seminist
values will actually just regulate
minimum Road Frontage and that's the way
they limit density it's not the lot size
but it's the frontage
so how tight is New Hampshire zoning if
we compare it to other states this is a
really difficult exercise I'm going to
give you a couple of different sources
here and they give somewhat different
results one is this Wharton residential
land use regulatory index that's
produced by some UPenn economists and
what they do is they survey thousands of
Municipal officials around the country
on a number of different things and some
of them are a little bit subjective like
how active are Town residents in showing
up to public hearings on new
developments and that that sort of thing
and they use the answers to those
questions to come up with a single index
of how restrictive zoning is
because it's a survey I think for
smaller States like New Hampshire it can
be kind of volatile and and we see this
in uh in the two ways of the survey that
they've done one was in 2005 and one was
in 2018. in 2005 New Hampshire looked
like the fourth most strict strictly
zoned state in the country after Hawaii
Rhode Island and Massachusetts
there's a little bit of face validity
there everyone knows Hawaii is very
strict land use regulations and other
New England states as well
um not to mention New Jersey then in the
2018 survey New Hampshire looks 31st so
New Hampshire actually looks like it's
just a just an average state in terms of
how strict zoning is
um did New Hampshire actually reduce
zoning that much in those 13 years I
mean we did get some Statewide
legislation that's been talked about
Workforce housing law and the Adu law I
don't think that
um that New Hampshire really dropped
that much but but there's probably some
volatility here because it's a small
state and when you're doing a survey
just the sample size is going to be
small for a small state
but you do see some again face validity
here in 2018 with New Jersey Maryland
Rhode Island California everyone knows
has very strict land use regulation all
showing up near the top here's another
source that's been used by economists a
couple of Harvard economists ganong and
shog have this this piece looking at
land use regulation and its effects on
the economy that's been widely cited
their measure of land use regulation is
State appellate decisions containing the
phrase land use cumulative from January
1st 1920 which is about when zoning
started divided by state population
so the idea here is that if you regulate
land use more strictly you're going to
get more land use conflicts and and uh
and more court cases and here New
Hampshire looks like the fifth strictest
state in the country
let's look at regulatory restrictions
across the territory of our state this
is forthcoming data that is not yet
available to the public from the New
Hampshire zoning Atlas this will be
released from the center for ethics and
Society uh next month
um and I was the the pi on that uh on
This research project
but we worked in hand in hand with OPD
and New Hampshire housing as well in uh
in in putting these data together and
raising funding for it so
um here are a few preview maps of of
what the um the zoning looks like in
these categories so we're going to look
at and how much of our land area is
single-family housing allowed on a small
lot that is under an acre and how much
of the state is a duplex allowed on a
small lot under an acre on how much in
how much of the state is a five family
structure allowed on a on a small lot
and here a small lot is defined as two
and a half acres so that's meeting that
same density of of two units per acre
um and then uh where a large adus
allowed you know larger than the state
requires and whereas manufactured
housing allowed
um so I'm going to show you first single
family and duplexes on small Lots you
see on the on the left hand side here uh
that the vast majority of the state does
not allow single family on small Lots
now in some cases you might say that
that this is the result of lacking
Wastewater infrastructure on the State
Department of Environmental Services
does regulate minimum lot size for
septic but most of those requirements
unless your soils are really bad or your
slopes are steep you can get septic on
less than an acre lot so in general most
towns are are requiring minimum lot
sizes for even for detached single
family that are higher than is strictly
necessary for a septic system
um and in fact the number here is 13 of
the buildable land area of the state is
available for small lot single family
and so you can see in Gray here these
are non-buildable areas White Mountain
National Forest interstate highways
so yeah so that's one uh under one acre
minimum lot size and under 200 feet of
minimum Road Frontage
that's right and so then for for small
duplex here we're saying uh we're
counting as a small uh small lot duplex
under an acre minimum lot size
um or more than uh and more than uh two
units per acre uh allowed
for for duplexes so uh so that uh some
some towns will will specify a maximum
density some will not and just specify
the minimum lot size so we wanted to
have both those criteria in there and
you can see that less of the state is
available for small lot duplexes
um and the figure here I believe is
about 10 percent of the buildable land
area is available for duplexes on small
Lots
okay and now let's look at five families
so five family you see actually
um more of the land areas available for
five family than for duplexes uh at
higher densities and that may be a
little bit surprising but I wonder if
this has something to do with the State
Workforce housing law again it requires
a reasonable and realistic opportunities
for Workforce housing multi-family
housing in that statute is defined as
five units or more in a structure so it
could be that some towns in order to
make sure that they're meeting the
statutory requirements allow for
five units on a fairly small small lot
but again it does tend to be
interestingly the more rural areas that
are allowing apartment buildings which
is where you wouldn't really expect a
lot of the demand to be you know
Pittsburgh New Hampshire and Clarksville
up there at the very top
um you know that's these are not places
where developers are are clamoring to
build residential Towers right and
that's it's just not a feasible or or
market-driven form of development out
there so in in terms of places where
there is that demand and more the
Southeastern part of the state you see
that it's still a a small share of the
land area that's available uh for this
again on small Lots right so a lot of
towns will allow five family on let's
say a 10 acre lot or larger but that's
not necessarily an economically
attractive uh proposition for a lot of
landowners
you'll see that a large majority of the
of the land area is available for large
adus and this varies mostly by town and
not by zoning District unlike the the
previous maps and the reason for this is
presumably again the state law that that
says wherever you allow single family
you also have to allow for adus and so
typically towns do not say you can have
this size Adu in this single family
district and this size Adu in a
different single-family District they
just have a single ordinance that covers
the entire land area and then finally
manufactured housing you see that the
vast majority of the buildable land area
of the state is available for
manufactured housing and again probably
because of State Statute that that
requires this on the majority of each
Town's land area you will see some towns
here that seemingly do not
um conform to state law
I'll just leave it there they may have
some explanation for that but this is
according to our measure we're not
seeing that they allow that on the
okay so uh once this is released and
you'll be hearing more about it in the
coming weeks this will be available at
this website
the New Hampshire zoning Atlas and
there'll be many more findings so this
is just a short little teaser
I'm going to give you a little bit more
information now about the origins and
effects of of zoning in New Hampshire
um so zoning was authorized by Statute
in 1926 around the time many other
states did it and some towns adopted it
almost immediately Keen Portsmouth
Manchester Concord Nashua fairly early
on more urban jurisdictions but also it
looks like some of the wealthier
jurisdictions in the state that are
certainly not very Urban in the 1930s
like Hanover and Durham uh also adopted
zoning very early on
and then we see another wave of zoning
adoption in the 1960s and 1970s periods
of very high growth in this state and
that's when a lot of the more Rural and
Suburban communities began to adopt
zoning explicitly as a way of
controlling growth and limiting how fast
um I've done some research for the
Josiah Bartlett Center that constructs a
measure of regulatory stringency by town
and that correlates positively with how
long zoning has been in place in other
words the longer zoning has been around
the stricter it tends to be
if you compare towns and there's a
little scatter plot here that shows that
relationship and you see just a handful
of towns adopt zoning early on
and then a bunch start uh adopting it in
the 60s and 70s and those are more
restrictive today apparently than uh
than those that adopted it in the 80s
90s and that's pretty much when the when
the zoning adoption stops Dalton tried
to do it and then it was voted down
again
um so uh what does this tell us it may
mean that some of the communities that
adopted zoning
um starting in the 50s 60s and 70s were
doing it again explicitly to try to
um so I'm going to just give you a very
little bit about how I constructed this
measure of regulatory stringency and
what it looks like for jurisdictions in
New Hampshire so what I did is I looked
at quality adjusted cost of housing by
year I have a data set of all
single-family home sales in the state
since 1997 something like 145 000 of
them and I look at how much do they cost
compared to what you'd expect given
features of the housing like how old it
is how many square footage how big the
lot size how many bedrooms how many
bathrooms and so on
um and then I average that by town like
how much does that housing cost more
than you would expect given uh its
features
and then I I look at
um population growth
all right and so population growth this
is coming out of our state's estimates
and it's based on the OPD data that um
that Ben Frost mentioned on on dwelling
units permitted
and so well the idea here is is that if
some towns are more costly than others
simply because of demand people want to
live there and they build up the cost of
housing
then we would probably expect those also
to do fast growing jurisdictions people
want to live there but they just can't
build new homes fast enough and so the
cost goes up but they're still growing
faster than places where people don't
want to live
but if restricted Supply is driving
costs then we shouldn't see that
relationship we should see costly towns
that are growing slowly because they've
restricted Supply people want to live
there but they can't because homes
aren't being built
and my result is that if I look at towns
that don't have zoning it is positive so
in towns that don't have zoning
um
demand is what drives the cost of
housing but everywhere else it seems
like it's restricted Supply that's
driving the cost of housing and so the
conclusion is that Supply restrictions
in the face of rising demand as
population grows are a big driver of
housing costs this might be a little bit
hard to uh to see but uh this is a cloud
of all towns on their population growth
on the x-axis and their excess price how
much how much more costly than average
they are probably not surprising that
Newcastle rye and Portsmouth and
Newington are extremely expensive towns
in the state but what's especially
interesting is that these towns are not
growing fast
and see these are towns that are growing
about the average for New Hampshire
whereas towns like Lincoln
uh you know those of us who like to go
to Loon uh you know it's a popular place
right so but it's that um that cost
growth is being driven by population
growth and then whereas like Stratford
and Clarks feel and places like that
um they're very cheap but people don't
want to live there there are no jobs
there so they're not they're not bidding
up the cost of housing there so
um the higher cost you are more than we
would expect given your population
growth that's my measure of how
restricted your supply is
okay
a little bit of technical detail there
but I think the results have some face
validity here so this is a map of a
restrictiveness of housing Supply by
municipality and we see that in the
Southeast housing Supply is more
restricted right darker colors are more
restricted we see some in The Lakes
region in in the Upper Valley and maybe
a little bit in the White Mountains are
a little bit restrictive and then sort
of the Appalachian spine up from
Cheshire county all the way up to koas
that's where Supply is not restricted
very much compared to the rest of the
state
and this isn't terribly surprising
because you would expect that the places
where people want to live that are under
having the population growth those are
precisely the places that are more
likely to adopt ordinance to manage that
growth and so that's going to be the
southern southern part of the state and
places where there are lots of amenities
like the Lakes region in the mountains
um so one of the effects of regulatory
stringency so I did some statistical
tests here to to look at this and and
there's there's a large economics
literature on this this is by no means
the first person to look at this but I I
am drilling down on on the case in in
New Hampshire
so what we see is that with population
growth over time it is slowed so in the
70s and the 80s we grew rapidly so 25
growth in the 70s 20 growth in the 80s
then down to 11 in the 90s 6.5 the 2000s
and then 4.6 population growth in the
2010s now what do we think is happening
there is New Hampshire becoming a less
and less desirable place to live and so
fewer and fewer people demand homes here
um or is it something else and my view
is that the the data suggests that it's
something else it's not that people
don't want to live here anymore for
whatever reason I mean our
whatever our crime rate is too high or
our taxes are too high that doesn't seem
to be what's going on here uh that those
things have not changed
um so what has changed is our cost of
living has gone way up so we're the
eighth most costly State according to
the Bureau of economic analysis we have
the second lowest fertility rate in the
country so one of the findings uh in the
literature is that the higher
um the more costly housing is the less
likely you are to get families to form
unless they're less likely to have kids
they can afford to they have to live in
a small apartment they can't afford a a
house and the space to have kids or they
have fewer kids because they don't have
that space and so it's not surprising
that our fertility rate would be so low
that people aren't having kids here and
so you combine the two things tends to
be older people who are wealthier and
can afford costly housing and uh costly
housing also causes young people to have
fewer kids or also the second oldest
state in the country by median age
uh this also means that the people who
tend to live and stay here the people
who move here the people who stay here
tend to be wealthier than average
because if you are poorer than average
you probably want to go move to Texas or
somewhere else that's cheap right and so
the research does show this that
Americans in general are moving away
from high-wage regions to low-wage
Regions which seems surprising why would
you move away from a high wage region to
a low-wage region and the answer is cost
of living because the low-wage regions
have even lower cost of living so once
you control for that you're actually
better off moving to the Sun Belt you
know from from California or the
Northeast because
you can afford the housing there
so we we have ended up with the eighth
highest median income in the country
maybe some of that is due to good
economic policies but probably a lot of
it is also just to this sorting effect
where only the wealthier people can
afford to live here I do also find
within New Hampshire there's more
socioeconomic segregation so again this
might be a little bit hard to read here
but uh in terms of the the town names
but the relationship here is is positive
between two variables the first is the
degree of housing regulation early in
the 2000s basically right so how
restrictive was regulation back then and
on the y-axis we have change in median
household income from 2000 to 2015.
okay so what we're finding with this
positive relationship is that places
that started out more regulated in the
early 2000s subsequently became richer
over the next decade and a half now why
did that happen was it that zoning laws
made their workers more productive and
they could earn more at work that
doesn't I don't I don't know any
mechanism that would account for that
but what's probably happening is that
lower income households are moving away
from the places that are more regulated
so what we tend to get is a kind of
bifurcation where some towns like
Amherst and Hanover and places like that
um don't grow very much but the people
who stay there are the wealthier ones
and then other towns like Kanan and
Allenstown and uh Pittsfield uh those
are the places that are affordable and
so lower income households tend to move
there and so you get lower income
households in some towns and higher
income households in other towns we get
that kind of increasing sort of
socioeconomic segregation in the state
all right um so that's that's it for me
um and I'm happy to answer any questions
you may have
thank you very much Miss orange are
representative Lorenzo thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question
um you know I'm looking at your maps and
data and stuff now you take a town like
Newington which has a very low tax rate
because of the you know the malls and
the industry around but
I predict that malls are dying what do
you think is going to happen to
Newington oh that's yeah it's hard to
it's hard to speculate but certainly you
would expect that if
um commercial tax base went down they'd
have to raise their taxes and that could
also reduce demand for housing there so
there's an interesting relationship in
that a town that has some good fortune
or good planning to attract commercial
development and reduce its tax rate then
sees people want to buy houses there to
take advantage of the lower tax rate and
so the value of homes goes up there I've
seen this in in my region I live in
Amherst
Bedford has lower tax rates and higher
home values than Amherst because Bedford
has allowed a little bit more
development and so you know you could
say that that is their good luck or it
could be their good planning to allow
for that and and you know provide the
represent walls thank you Mr chairman uh
could you email this PowerPoint
presentation to the committee absolutely
excellent work by the way thank you
representative um McConkey thank you
thank you Mr chairman so one of one of
the areas or probably other than adus on
your uh Maps if I was paying attention
correctly was manufactured homes and I
know up north several towns had parks
and they didn't want more Parks so then
they says more homes could be out
manufactured homes could be on land
right as opposed to an art
and I don't see
a movement when you look at the cost of
developing a manufactured home parks or
higher density for that
clustered yeah and most towns then Zone
that out because they want one per acre
and so forth but it would seem that
manufactured homes
have great opportunity from what you say
that's right and um this does not
distinguish between this map does not
distinguish between parks and individual
Lots but we have that data and so once
the the Alice is released we'll show
where our manufactured homes allowed in
parks where they allowed on individual
Lots where are they allowed on either
way
um and I can say just
impressionistically based on on my work
on these data that yeah most towns are
leaning toward allowing them on
individual Lots but not in Parks but
there are there are many that go the
other way and so it tends to be you know
towns that are very worried about a
certain conception of community
character will often say yes have a lot
of parks over in this part of town but
then no manufactured housing anywhere
else whereas those that don't
you know so much care will allow them
anywhere and and you you see that um you
know I've just noticed driving around
there are more manufactured housing
Parks than you'd expect they're tucked
away in various places and they don't
often look like it but even Amherst has
them and you would think that uh you
know a town like Amherst would have
tried to Zone them out but they haven't
so but some form they're allowed they're
allowed most of the state
representative Walsh
thank you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question
and maybe you know also we talk
manufactured homes how about ordinances
against mobile homes because I I have a
picture in my mind what a manufactured
home is it comes in on a trailer you put
both halves together that's manufactured
but a mobile home you're backing on a
slab and the axles and the tongue stay
right on it are those what do you have
any study on whether those are allowed
around the state yeah so according to
state law mobile homes count as
manufactured homes so
um so yeah so towns are no longer
allowed to make a distinction between
they um they count the mobile homes as
manufactured homes and then a lot of
people call me and I don't I don't sell
trailers you know we do the modular
homes but a lot of people are inquiring
you know about the manufactured homes
but you don't get a lot of them on
single family lots because the land's so
expensive
right you know you're going to buy a an
expensive lot and put a mobile home on
it it's
right you don't see that very often no
yeah not the best bang for your buck
yeah and there's there's obviously
modular pre-site built housing is
another affordable option that uh and we
didn't we didn't code this explicitly
but I haven't seen any ordinance that
tries to restrict pre-site built housing
okay oh thank you okay
um just for clarification modular
manufactured and mobile homes are all
set on us at this point in time but I
think of a modular home it's something
that might be a bit more involved than a
ranch with two halves I used to work at
Westfield when I was back today we would
you know you'd have a 3 000 square foot
Garrison would be six modules and uh
stacked with a crane but that's all
encompassing is it not
um actually well pre-site built housing
where you have like prefab sections of
the house that you then come and put
together on a fixed Foundation that's
not considered manufactured housing
actually manufactured housing is if it's
the whole unit
anyone else representative McConkey
having owned several Parks uh
manufactured home comes complete as you
said heating system you tie in the water
your town and tie in the sewer modular
comes off the frame there's it's it was
the stigma of mobile home that's been
well thank you I'm I I just have a
question with you know our charge on the
committee is to help alleviate the
housing crisis and you're an expert on
New Hampshire zoning laws so if you had
you know there's no magic bullet but
if you had some sort of suggestion what
would you give us
yeah I mean um you know I'm not here to
Advocate on on behalf of any particular
policies but I will say that um
certainly land use regulations are
appear to be according to this research
a big part of the restriction and supply
and rise in cost of housing and so in
general if if the state can incentivize
or maybe even judiciously mandate
zoning changes for municipalities that
would allow for more housing of various
types that is going to result in more
housing and and a decrease in costs uh
now exactly how you do that is obviously
there are many ideas and there are
several bills in the in the current
session and and uh I'm even testify
about some of them but um but I will say
that uh this is an area that deserves
I mean I feel ashamed to not have more
questions because I love I like there's
just like so much data that I feel like
it's just right for questions but
um
but you explained it very well so I
guess I didn't have that many but
um
so you seem to be focused a lot on
um the specific zoning
um
um kind of restrictions
um did you
account for or uh control for kind of
like regulatory
apparatuses we were talking about like
fire earlier today we were talking about
like um maybe code
um enforcements that
may be layered on top of zoning that may
be an issue uh
did you stumble on any of that or
control for that or how what what did
you I mean some some towns do amend the
State Building Code and in general I
would expect that those amendments would
add at least a little bit to the cost of
housing because it's just at least
something else to to deal with and learn
about and maybe get a a permit for as a
as a um as a developer
um but these are those are not part of
the zoning Atlas
um they don't regulate any of the
variables that we track in terms of the
dimensions of lots or size of buildings
or
um uh you know one versus five family
structures
um there is some research out there from
other experts around the country who
have looked at life safety and energy
codes and to what extent they have some
impact on the cost of housing
um there there's definitely much much
secondary to to zoning regulations but
um there aren't maybe a few things in
the building code that contribute to the
cost of housing a very popular one that
that researchers are talking a lot about
now is
um multiple stairway requirements in
multi-family buildings that that ends up
using a lot of space and requiring an
interior Corridor
um so in Europe for instance building
codes don't require that at least up to
a certain height so there's
um possibly some potential for reform
there
yeah
thank you um
what about
um
these
we talked you kind of touched a little
bit about
um
places going above and beyond kind of
like this the soil requirements of of uh
of uh
this the area right so they're saying
you know you can only have one lot per
or one one unit per acre let's say when
when the ground could sustain three
units per acre or something like that do
you think that um did you
uh in my town we definitely only look at
like unit like lot size acre
um but I I recently heard from someone
in one of the towns I represent that
they
um are much more focused on
um not saying necessarily A Lot unit per
acre but saying like unit per soil type
or like per acre kind of a thing
um did you
sure
um did you do any research as far as uh
of that of how how widespread that
effort is to say like we're going to set
some metrics for size based on based on
uh soil types or the conditions on the
ground versus where we you know like to
centrally plan we just think that 200
square 200 foot Frontage looks best or
whatever kind of a thing and so that's
what they they impose do you did you do
any of that kind of research yeah so
this there's quite a bit of variation
there quite a few communities uh very
minimum lot sizes or frontages or
maximum densities by availability of
utilities water and sewer and by soil
type so Londonderry for instance does a
little of both so there's a you know if
you have sewer you don't look at the
soil map but if you don't then you do
look at this at the soil map on to
determine what the density is
um in the large majority of cases
municipalities are requiring a lower
density than the Des requires for septic
um so it is still soil based but it's
not necessarily exactly the same as what
the state says is a uh you know is uh is
an acceptable density to to allow uh
representative cocky
thank you Mr chairman in that
conversation you you haven't actually
tallied who those towns are have you
um I have uh that this is in the in the
data set we have a um we we look at
whether the minimum lot size can vary by
other conditions and would just say you
know we have the average the average
minimum lot size over the conditions and
then we have like the minimum like under
ideal conditions what would your minimum
lot size be and then the maximum under
the worst possible conditions what would
your minimum lot size be so that's all
in the in this vast spreadsheet that we
put together thank you that'd be worth
seeing thank you yeah and when does that
come out it's supposed to come out next
month
um I've heard the the date March 20
floated but it could be we'll have to
see right the website is still being
built so we don't know for certain
um but uh yeah the the data set is is
large you've got about 200 variables and
there are two over two thousand zoning
districts so it's well over 400 000
individual pieces of data so there's a
lot to dig into that's like a lot of
internal yeah
um are you
um are you interested in coming back
when it comes out with um maybe your
counterpart from CNAs absolutely um
present on more in detail on that so
probably the end of March early April
happy to do that perfectly
all right so I feel like we've had a
long pack day I've learned a lot
um I think that maybe we can come back
in a few weeks and discuss before we
have more presentations about what we
learned kind of refresh our memories on
stuff and go forward but I kind of have
a couple things that I'd like to look at
in the rsas so um but if you have any
suggestions of people to come present
um about housing I think representative
Gibbs suggested a few
um just feel free to send them my way
yep so can you block off where is it
yes the morning of the 17th
um yeah well not the afternoon but the
morning in case you're doing
start recruiting
March I'm looking at March 17th from 9
nine to noon we wouldn't go in the
afternoon
fourth and uh in the thirty person but
um definitely definitely March 31st
Please block that off I have people
coming from Virginia
um a think tank in Virginia yeah we'll
keep the 17th up in here
representative Rudy doesn't want to meet
it's going to be a committee it's going
yeah perfect well if there's anything
else like to adjourn
thanks guys
foreign